mes chers collègues dans le cadre de
notre étude sur l'adaptation des modes
d'action de l'État dans les outrem nous
auditionnons ce matin le général Lionel
Laverne commandant de la gendarmerie
d'outremer communément appelé
sgom général nous vous remercions
d'avoir accepté notre invitation après
un parcours prestigieux vous avez été
nommé il y a un an à la tête du
commandement de la gendarmerie
d'outremer qui administre les les
personnels en outr-emer donc à la
lumière de de vos responsabilités de
votre expérience des contacts que vous
avez avec le terrain
euh vous allez nous éclairer sur vos vos
moyens et vos modalités d'action dans
les territoires ultramarins les règles
et les normes que vous appliquez dans le
cadre de vos missions de gendarmerie
vous paraissent-elles adapté au
caractéristiques des Outremers les
trouvez-vous perfectibles comment se
coordonnent les différents service de de
sécurité avec la police nationale avec
les polices locales municipales
territoriale la douane donc nous
n'ignorons pas les immenses défis que
vous avez à relever que ce soit en
Guyane à Mayotte mais aussi après le
passage de de l'ouragon Béal à à la
Réunion
et nous allons vous laisser la parole un
propos
liminaire comme vous le voulez d'une
dizaine ou vingtaine de minutes puis
après je céderai la parole à notre à nos
rapporteurs donc Philippe Bas ici
présent Victor Lurel qui a quelques
petits soucis de de connexion et enfin
au collègue ici présents qui euh
souhaiteraiit vous interroger sur des
sujets un peu plus spécifique à votre à
votre fonction dans leur territoire
général je vous laisse la
parole madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice merci beaucoup
euh monsieur le ministre mesdames
mesdames Messieurs les les sénatrices je
tiens d'abord à à dire que je suis très
honoré d'être devant vous hein
aujourd'hui parce que je je reviens une
nouvelle fois au au au Sénat et céit
avec avec grand plaisir hein pour
pouvoir vous délivrer mon appréciation
de
la dans les dans les territoires
ultramarins et puis pour pouvoir
échanger avec vous et et vraiment à
Batton rompu je vous le dis parce que le
but c'est de c'est que on on construise
ensemble effectivement ben cette
évolution qui est
nécessaire et qui doit et que notre état
doit doit continuellement s'adapter à
nos territoires et en particulier
territoires ultraarin donc
je les questions m'aviez envoyé moi ce
que je vous
propose c'est de de faire un propos
liminaire qui va aborder certaines des
questions de manière assez profonde le
but c'est pas de faire un grand propos
liminaire mais je vous donne un état des
lieux de ce généralement intremè la
manière dont nous concevons notre action
dont nous la faisons évoluer et avec nos
particularités bien évidemment puis N
puis après après je après la la les
questions j j'y répondrai mais bien
volontiers de manière totalement
transparente je précise que je suis
accompagné à ma gauche donc du
lieutenant colonel ludoric Provo que qui
qui est un habitué des lieux puisque a
travaillé ici pendant pendant pendant 4
ans c'est un L réserviste je je
précise opérationnel
spécialiste que j'ai recru côté comme
comme conseiller territorial puisque
nous avons fait ensemble liasheden il y
a 10 ans voilà donc ça me permet aussi
de m'entourer pas que de gendarmes je
dirais avec le statut d'active mais avec
des des gendarmes je dirais de cœur hein
comme comme le con Provot et qui et qui
me donne d'autres éclairages aussi et ce
qui est très intéressant voilà
euh tout
d'abord sujet dans le vif du sujet je
voudrais que je souhaiteris aborder
quelques données clés et quelques
paramètres
importants pour moi de ce qui ce que
représente la gendarmerie dans les
outremers la gendarmerie dans les
outr-emers c'est 7200 militaires et
civils répartis sur les trois océans et
l'Amérique du Sud avec la la
Guyane ces 7200 militaires sont répartis
en 3900 officiers sous-officiers
affectés dans les territoires
ultramarins
réservistes les réservistes étant tous
des
originaires et ça c'est une dimension
importante 1500 gendarmes mobiles donc
des gendarmes mobiles qui arrivent en
renfort donc qui ne sont pas
affectés et 300 membres du G avec des
antennes du G outreem ça fait en gros
7200 militaires et civil quand je dis
civil c'est pour aussi l'aspect soutien
parce que bien évidemment il y a une
forme sur laquelle je reviendrai
d'autonomie euh de la part des des
commandements dans les dans les
territoires c'est 7200 militaires sont
répartis en 10 commandements de la
gendarmerie ce qu'on appelle communément
vous avez dû entendre parler dans sur
vos différents territoires les comjand
c'est c'est l'acronyme je vais je vais
essayer d'être très simple évidemment
d'éviter les acronymes mais bon com jand
c'est un acronyme je pense qui qui est
connu de de vous toutes et tous euh 10
com jand et le 10e com jand a été créé
très récemment puisque c'est le com jand
Ben qui qui concerne madame la
Présidente hein c'est le com jand de
saint-barthelémie
Saint-Martin et d'ailleurs ce comm jeand
consacre aussi illustre l'évolution
aussi de l'état euh et et de son ancrage
territorial et sa proximité aussi avec
l'étatut TR ultramarin parce que euh
pour l'instant il y a pas de préfet de
plein exercice à saint-bartéémis
Saint-Martin puisque c'est encore un
préfet délégué de la Guadeloupe mais sur
la volonté du ministre de l'Intérieur
euh il y aura je pense dans les toutes
prochaines semaines la nomination d'un
préfet mais nous on a anticipé et on
s'est mis en ordre de bataille pour
créer un
commandement qui est viable depuis le 2
janvier donc de cette année c'est ce
n'est plus une compagnie de la
Guadeloupe c'est un commandement propre
qui encadre ces ces deux collectivités
que sont Saint-Martin et
saint-bartelémi c'est la gendarmerie
dans les autres mè c'est 8
% du territoire en matière de
responsabilité de sécurité publique on a
communément on a l'habitude de dire que
c'est 95 % du territoire national la GIE
est 50 % de la
population outreem c'est 99 % en
responsabilité de tranquillité publique
et c'est surtout 70 % de la population
donc on voit très bien que outre mer la
gerie a un point important à
des à des devoirs importants vis-à-vis
de citoyen
euh ça représente au niveau de la
gendarmie nationale 5,5 % des
effectifs c'est 5,5 % que l'on compte
même en englobant nos réservistes qui
sont pour l'instant à hauteur de
35000 donc en grosso modo ça fait 7200
par rapport à 135000 ça fait 5 quasiment
5,5
%. la gén oututreem dans des paramètres
qui vont vous parler tout de suite se
caractérisent par nos territoire par un
éloignement de
l'Hexagone on a jusqu'à 20000 km de
distance avec des liaisons qui sont
parfois dépendantes des des impératifs
naturels ou géopolitiques très
clairement
euh cet éloignement favorise je dirais
et impose pour moi la notion d'équipe
France et c'est ce que je vois quand je
me déplace dans les territoires
euh les équipes France c'est le préfet
le procureur les autorités judiciaires
les chefs de service on a vraiment
l'impression effectivement et c'est
nécessaire quand on est loin et bien on
est plus soudé et ça c'est
caractéristique et je trouve que c'est
très important de le souligner hein
cette notion d'équipe France parce qu'on
est ils sont seuls en fait ils sont loin
de l'hexagone et ils ont une autonomie
relative même s'il peutarder des
renforts donc il faut qu'il fonctionne
ça fonctionne très bien entre eux et ça
répond à une de vos questions en matière
de de coordination et et je dirais
d'interopérabilité je dirais
interserviste au niveau de
l'État c'est un un autre paramètre très
important pour moi c'est le décalage
temporel décalage horaire euh moi sur
les 10 comm jandes j'ai SEP créneaux
horaires avec une amplitude de 21h en
hiver et 23h en été d'ailleurs le
commandement que j'exerce ça un
commandement qu'on a coutume de dire sur
lequel le soleil ne se couche jamais par
exemple ce matin j'avais encore ben j'ai
eu le général commandant la Calédonie le
général matateos voilà bah c'est comme
ça il faut s'adapter et c'est c'est une
contrainte aussi je ne peux pas avoir
tous mes commandements rassemblés je les
convoque à Paris on fait des séminaires
mais quand j'ai besoin de leur de les
maintenir dans une dynamique aussi parce
que c'est important ben je fais des des
des visos le matin et le soir pour tenir
compte et ben le soir c'est le Pacifique
et le matin c'est l'océan Atlantique et
et et et le et l'océan
Indien c'est un isolement aussi les
territoires ultramarins un isolement qui
est qui est différent et qui est accru
plus accru sur certains
territoires je pense notamment à
Saint-Pierre et miclon je pense
notamment à Wallis et Futuna euh moi
j'ai l'occasion pour l'instant de faire
j'ai fait tout le tour des territoires
marin sauf Saint-Pierre mlon où je me
rends dans 10 jours mais je je souvenir
de Futuna Futuna on est au bout du monde
Futuna on est au confin de la
République pour aller à Futuna on on est
obligé de passer par walis il y a pas de
liaison avec les Fidji et c'est une
réalité c'est une très grosse
contrainte c'est aussi une forme de je
dirais je dirais pas d'austérité des
moyens mais des moyens qui sont comptés
aussi de l'état très clairement parce
qu'on fait on fait en sorte d'être
autonome voilà
donc certains comme jand sont sont comme
jand sont armés avec beaucoup de
personnel d'autres avec moins de
personnels les territoires dont j'ai
parlé Saint-Pier miclon et waliss Futuna
c'est moins de 30
militaires donc les militaires font font
un peu
tout ce sont des milieux également les
territoires ultramarins sont des milieux
qui
sont
atypique atypique parce que on a des une
phie qui est très particulière je pense
notamment à la forêt équatoriale en
Guyane à tout ce qui est littoral les
zones humides au Terres
australes et ça c'est
important c'est no territoir ultramarin
c'est aussi pour moi le un contact
important
avec nos voisins donc un contact avec
l'international qui est fondamental
parce que les problématiques à laquelle
nous sommes confrontés sur sur sur nos
territoires sont interdépendants avec
notre voisinage immédiat je rappelle
que les territoires les les territoires
outreem
euh dans ont dans leur proximité 35
pays donc la la la notion de coopération
internationale de proximité pour moi est
fondamentale quand on est en Martinique
on voit sainlcie quand on est au sud de
la Martinique et on sait ce qui se passe
avec saintte-lucie quand on est à Marie
Galante on voit la
Dominique donc forcément il y a une
interdépendance B de phénomènes
délictuel et criminels bien
évidemment
euh c'est également un grand écart les
territoires ultrarins c'est un grand
écart c'est comme ça que je le qualifie
des statuts juridiques des cultures et
des identités et donc il faut que le
gendarme il s'adapte à ça et ça c'est
fondamental on n'exerce pas le métier de
gendarme outreem comment on le fait dans
l'Hexagone ce sont des phénomènes
également de délinquences qui sont
importants les territoires ultramarins
je vais vous donner quelques chiffres
euh quelques indicateurs qui pour moi
sont très éclairant
euh je vais vous donner des ratios par
rapport à la à l'ensemble de la
gendarmie nationale les territoires
ultramarins c'est 15 % des atteintes aux
bien donc tout ça il faut mettre en
regard par rapport à à 5,5 % de
gendarmes donc 5,5 % de gendarmes dans
les territoires outremer c'est 15 % des
Attin au bien
constatés c'est 25 % des atteintes aux
personnes c'est 10 % des violences
intrafiliales qui gangrainent nos
territoires
ultramarins c'est 30 % des homicides et
tentativees
d'omicide c'est plus de 50 % des vols à
ma armée et là je parle toujours de
constater par la gendarmerie
nationale un éclairage sur les vols à ma
armée
un/ers des voles à armé par arme à feu
constaté par la gendarmie nationale et
je parle d'année 2023 qui vient de de
s'éteindre ont sont été perpétrés en
Guyane
un/ers un/ers des vols à
armé commis par arme blanche
ont été perpétrés à
Mayotte pour
2023 c'est la grem c'est également 1/4
de la grande criminalité donc on a la
délinquence de droit commun et on a la
grande criminalité c'est 1/4 de la
grande criminalité
50 % des règlements de compte constatés
par la gendarmie nationale le sont en
Guyane
et donc ça veut dire que nos
gendarmes qui qui produisent la sécurité
au profit de nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens dans les territoires
ultramarins sont soumis à une violence
qui est plus importante que dans
l'Hexagone et je terminerai par là sur C
sur ces indicateurs là là je les ai
sortis hier 50 % du nombre d'agressions
pour
2023 de toute la Gendarmerie nationale
ont été commises dans les territoires
ultramarins 50 % et là je parle gendarme
départementaux et gendarmes mobile ça
fait référence au 7200 donc au 5,5 % 50
% et c'est ça représente c'est 50 % 25 %
des blessés de la gendarmerie donc 1/4
des blessés de la gendarmerie pour les
2023 ont été blessés outreemè blessé
gendarme blessé blessé
blessé il me semblait important de
donner ces éclairages là ces indicateurs
qui qui qui alors faut pas dresser non
plus un tableau trop noir des outrm je
suis pas en train de dire c'est la
guerre non non c'est pas du tout ça
c'est là je vous livre des chiffres qui
montrent effectivement la réalité de ce
que vous vivez de ce que nous vivons
dans les territoires
ultramarins et ben par rapport à tout ça
toutes ces toutes ces particularités
toutes toutes ces singularités mais la
gendarmerie est une est une institution
qui s'adapte en permanence
et qui essae de d'être en constante
évolution et de se remettre en question
donc c'est c'est dit comme G comme je le
disais c'est une gendie qui s'adapte à
la fois au niveau local comme au niveau
central c'estie qui n'est pas seule bien
évidemment à travailler en coordination
en interservice l'autorité du préfet
avec les magistrats pour ce qui relève
de de l'activité judiciaire et c'est
d'une gendarmerie
outreem qui qui moi je j'ai coutume de
dire qui qui travaille sur le plan local
mais qui qui qui doit travailler
également sur le plan central parce que
les ce qui est produit dans les
territoires ultramarins l' localement
mais l' aussi sur le plan parisien on le
vit
tous donc moi mon rôle par exemple en
tant que commandant de G outrem c'est
comme c'est c'est comme le vôtre en fait
c'est une oscillation permanente entre
le terrain et Paris et c'est une forme
de trait d'union c'est comme ça que j'ai
coutume de dire de manière parce que moi
je délivre des appréciations de
situation moi à mon à mon directeur
général au cabinet du ministre bien
évidemment à tout l'écosystème parisien
hein des outresmèes qui tiennent compte
de cette de cette granularité ce
discernement nécessaire entre chaque
territoire on peut pas traiter les
territoires de manière globale comme ça
c'est pas possible et donc il y a c'est
des solutions parfois qui sont au cas
par cas adapté au territoire et ça c'est
fondamental pour moi et ça c'est c'est
l' un de mes défis en tant que qu' JRE
mè l'adaptation aussi c'est les
nouvelles brigades vous l'avez vu
effectivement parce que on avait perdu
un certain nombre de brigades durant 20
ans mais là on va recréer jusqu'en 2027
230 39 brigades dont 22 outremè et sur
les 22 outremè en 2024 c'est c'est 8
hein qui vont être créé dans les dans
les territoires 22 outreemè absolument
22 et sur les 22 c'est 14 brigades
mobiles exactement et brigades fixes les
brigades mobiles c'est des brigades qui
ont vocation à avoir une thématique
particulière par exemple une brigade
mobile je pense notamment à la Réunion
une des brigades mobiles centré sur le
contentieux violence intra familiale qui
qui qui qui gangraine quand même notre
plan de charge très
clairement
euh c'est également la gendie dans les
outr mè un dispositif opérationnel
souple et résilient et ça c'est
important puisqu'on est éloigné des
territoires comme je disais tout à
l'heure c'est sont des comjandes qui
sont doté de moyens et d'unité d'appui
que l'on retrouve habituellement au
niveau régional voire zonal dans
l'Hexagone ce n'est pas c'est pas un
département de l'Hexagone c'est si on on
fait une similitude c'est une région
zonale ou pas donc qu' y a des moyens
d'autonomie pour gérer des situation
parfois d'urgence ou de crise en
attendant effectivement ben les renforts
qui mettent du temps parfois arrivriver
on voit très bien sur la Réunion
récemment à un moment donné ben on a la
capacité de gérer mais il faut du temps
pour que les renfroid arrivent bon là
c'est sur une sur une crise climatique
mais ça peut être aussi sur une crise de
d'ordre
public ça veut dire concrètement ça veut
dire qu'on a des moyens lic sur place on
a des unités spécialisées de recherche
d'investigation judiciaire on a le gène
qui a des antennes partout dans les
territoires ultramarins on a des moyens
nautiques on a des moyens aussi de
montagne par exemple à la Réunion voilà
il y a une forme d'autonomie on a doté
ces territoires là de capacités
propres c'est la mise en place
également de structure dédié à la
gestion de phénomènes
criminels très clairement on a mis en
place au niveau de la gendarmerie des
task forces qui sont destinées à appuyer
les les com jandes en liaison avec les
autorités judiciaires sur des phénomènes
particuliers lorsqu'on a des enquêtes en
cours c'est le cas par exemple çaétait
le cas en Guyane c'est le cas à Mayotte
actuellement ça sera le cas je pense
prochainement aux Antilles voilà donc là
l'idée c'est pas de les laisser seul
avec leur moyen c'est d'assurer une
supervision de ce qu'il faut un contrôle
et dès que on a des phénomènes qui ne
peuvent pas être résolus avec les moyens
locaux on anticipe on envoie des tasqu
force pour leur faire franchir un
braquet supplémentaire un cap et la
Tasque force c'est l'envoi de
spécialiste dans un temps et pour un
espace un phénomène donné et après ça
revient sur Paris et cetera et le but
c'est d'être souple et réactif comme ça
ça peut être par exemple des tasques
forces sur la partie économique et
financière des Tasque fort sur ce qu'on
a fait en guyan sur les factions armées
brésiliennes
voilà dans les territoires outrem c'est
aussi des des unités spécialisées et
adaptées au territoire comme je vous le
disais par exemple ce qui me vient en
tête on a des un groupe jungle à la
section de recherche de Cayenne section
de recherche c'est ce qu' a de le plus
haut niveau en matière d'investigation
judiciaire mais on a créé on a créé un
groupe jungle parce que les
investigations se font également en
jungle
se font pas que sur le littoral bien
évidemment ce sont des moyens également
techniques et humains qui sont qu'on
essaie de d'être de d'être faire en
sorte qu'il soit innovant par exemple
c'est quelque chose qui a très bien
fonctionné là récemment et qu'on a mis à
profil nos camarades de la police
nationale je sais pas si vous avez en
tête mais il y a eu un triple meurtre en
à Cayenne il y a quelques jours de
commerçants chinois
euh il y a bah il y a un ADN il y a un
un ADN qui a étaé révélé et nous on a la
par nos camarades de la police et nous
on a un système qui permet effectivement
à partir de l'analyse de de l'ADN
prélevé de le comparer directement aux
base sur sur l'hexagone et ça a permis
de matcher et de faire avancer enquête
et ce qui a permis effectivement enfin
d'interpeller la personne et ils l'ont
interpellé finalement en Chine c'est
autité chinis qui l'ont interpellé donc
c'est des c'est des capacités innovantes
qui sont très intéressantes c'est
également par exemple on est en train on
a mis en place depuis 2 ans là
maintenant et là on a un stage qui va
commencer ceon ce qu'on appelle les
officiers de police judiciaire de
l'avant sont les officiers de police
judiciaire qui sont formés pour être
intégrés dans les unités de maintien de
l'ordre parce que il vous aura pas
échappé que par exemple sur Mayotte il y
a beaucoup
d'exaction en matière de trouble à
l'ordre public on a besoin de
matérialiser les infractions de manière
à ce que les personnes interpellées
puissent comparaître devant la justice
et donc on a mis en place un système
d'officiers de PO judiciaire intégré au
dispositif de manière à constater et une
fois que les gens sont interpellés aller
rapidement en flagrant délit pour
pouvoir déférer les gens et les faire
condamné ce sont également la génalie
s'adapte ce sont également des
dispositifs qui sont prévus euh qui sont
planifiés je pense notamment à
l'opération harpill en Guyane je pense
notamment aux opérations par exemple le
3è référendum en décembre 2021 en
Nouvelle-Calédonie je pense plus
récemment à l'opération qui n'a pas de
nom mais la presse le nom de l'opération
à Mayotte hein de avril à août dernier
voilà donc voilà c'est on on essaie de
faire en sorte et je je je j'en parlais
tout à l'heure dans le cadre de ma de
cap que je donne à mes unités de faire
en sorte de pas rester quelque part
j'oserais dire les deux pieds dans le
même sabot mais de faire en sorte de
pouvoir faire évoluer la chose à la fois
localement et nationalement avec un avec
un appui national qui pour moi est
nécessaire parce qu'on peut pas se
permettre de toujours rajouter des
moyens rajouter des moyens je veux dire
la le le la conséquence ou le donc c'est
pas forcément des moyens c'est au départ
quel diagnostic et et à un moment donné
ce diagnostic là aboutit à des moyens
qui viennent du du niveau central on
peut pas toujours ajouter tout le temps
des moyens sur le plan
local je je laisserai libre cours aux
questions parce que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire je dirais simplement que
on a une gestion ressources humaines
bien évidemment qui est spécifique à ce
à ce à ce modèle gendarmerie
outrem je pourrais revenir avec
volontiers effectivement sur la gestion
ressources humaines sur le recrutement
sur les temps d'affectation sur la la
nécessaire équilibre entre originaire et
non originaire dans les territoires
ultramarins parce que il y a le lien
avec la population qui est essentiel et
ce lien avec la population se fait
également et aussi avec la présence
d'originaire c'est également sur le plan
logistique une logistique effectivement
outreem qui est tournée vers le soutien
opérationnel et qui contribue aussi à
l'économie locale très clairement hein
moi je favorise pleinement effectivement
les achats locaux on n'est pas on est
peu sur les achats au niveau au niveau
central on est beaucoup sur les achats
locaux avec la problématique et qui qui
pour moi peut paraître je vous dirais un
paradoxe aussi hein c'est c'est log 3 de
mer parce queon a une double taxation
hein à la fois TVA et ctroit de mer
bon ça c'est ça c'est un sujet
euh mais ça je pourra y revenir on a un
vrai sujet sur le plan du soutien c'est
l'immobilier parce que dans le système
d'armes gendarmerie l'immobilier est
essentiel je précise qu'on a 196
casernes
outrem dont 155 domanial et 41 locativ
don quasiment 200 casernes dont les 3/4
dont les 3/4 sont des casernes
domanial et parfois dans un état qui est
qui qui mérite une attention
particulière voilà je fais je fais un
peu des focales là parce que je j'en
parle pas dans le détail parce que je
vais faire que parler autrement mais
c'est pour
laisser bah oui
non c'est pas orienté que pas du tout
c'est c'est pas mon
style non mais c'est important
l'immobilier en plus on est
fragileimmobilier c'est je veux dire on
peut pas dire que tout va bien c'est
c'est évident c'est évident mais ça pour
moi c'est un vrai sujet et je l'exemple
dernièrement j'étais en Guadeloupe la
semaine dernière à Guadeloupe
effectivement il y a beaucoup de domagal
et il y a deagal qui est pas en très bon
état donc on on est obligé de faire des
des
choix et je terminerai en disant qu'en
fait moi cette gendarmerie gendarmerie
outremer et donc pour répondre
euh à votre question au sujet de l'étude
l'adaptation des modes d'action de
l'État et donc dans la Gén pour ce qui
me concerne dans les territoires
ultramarins moi au bout d'un an je fixe
un cap à mes unités qui a un cap qui qui
qui est déclinaison en fait du de la
stratégie mon directeur général bien
évidemment et de celle du ministre mais
le cap en fait je vais vous dire il se
distingue en trois axes très simplement
le premier axe moi que je donne c'est
travailler densifier empreinte
territoriale très
clairement afin
d'intensifier la proximité avec la
population et les élus et je pense que
on a une marche de progrès pour
travailler au profit des populations les
plus vulnérables on peut avoir tendance
à s'adresser aussi aux
populations chez chez lesquelles tout va
bien mais c'est quand même la production
de sécurité elle doit être au profit de
tous et je pense qu'il faut avoir une
pensée particulière sur les populations
les plus vulnérable et et il y en a dans
les territoires ultramarins très
clairement donc ça c'est c'est une
source d'attention hein très importante
euh et quand je dis ça la déclinaison ça
va être le plan 200 brigades dont je
parlais ça va être
également les originaires dont je
parlais en matière de ressources
humaines la présence d'originaire c'est
également tout ce qui est classe de CAD
les le SNU très important les gendarmes
jint volontaire les classes
préparatoires intégrées tout ce qui se
lie avec la population des recrutements
de gendarmes adjoints adaptés par
exemple on ne recrute pas gendarmjouint
volontaire dans l'Hexagone qu'on me le
recrute outreem on lui pose pas les
mêmes questions concrètement ça vous
paraître évident mais un gendarm joint
en Guyane et bien le Guyanais ben on lui
demande pas quel quel est le le fleuve
le plus le plus long de l'Hexagone ou de
ou de la France on va lui demander ben
quels sont est-ce que tu connais déjà
bien ta géographie la géographie de ton
TER territoire et et et et donc ça c'est
des choses qui sont hyper importantes et
ce lien avec le territoire pour moi est
essentiel
euh deuxième AX d'effort c'est
rechercher des modes d'action innovants
dont je parlais tout à l'heure et par
exemple un des mode d'action innovant
que moi j'ai mis en place sous
l'autorité de mon directeur général
c'est j'ai lancé une expérimentation sur
l'ensemble des territoire ultramarin
pour
décloisonner le renseignement d'ordre
administratif le renseignement d'ordre
public et le renseignement judiciaire
parce qu'on a même en in gendarmerie on
a coutume de dire que G c'est un système
qui est intégré mais au sein de cette
intégration on a des chaînes le
judiciaire l'administratif et moi je
pense qu'on peut aller plus loin en
matière de renseignement en
décloisonnant le
renseignement par exemple chaque
comjande avait jusqu'àalors un officier
adjoint chargé de la poli judiciaire et
un officier adjoint chargé du
renseignement ben maintenant il n'y a
plus qu'une seule chaîne c'est officier
adjoint chargé de la police judiciaire
et du renseignement un chef et un
adjoint et le but c'est de décloisonner
bien sûr dans le respect du droit d'en
connaître du besoin d'en connaître bien
évidemment mais le but dans dans tout ça
c'est de pouvoir faire en sorte de mieux
gérer l'ensemble des informations dont
on dispose et qui viennent du terrain
avoir une approche un peu de de masse
des informations et des une approche qui
permette d'avoir une meilleure
cartographie des phénomènes auxquels on
est on est confronté dans les différents
territoires ultramarins et cette
cartographie doit nous aider à mieux
comprendre et bien ce qui ronge
effectivement nos territoires de manière
à mieux cibler notre action et donc euh
a pour but à la fois de délivrer aux
autorités administratives le préfet
autorité judiciaire des des contex des
contextes particuliers ou des
décryptages particuliers pour orienter
notre action et pour moi c'est essentiel
et on voit très bien que euh ben on a on
peut avoir du mal euh dans certains
territoires à à répondre à la question
de quoi s'agit-il à quoi nous
sommes-nous confrontés alors on y arrive
mais je pense qu'on peut encore faire
mieux en décloisonnant et en ayant une
approche une approche ciblée de
l'ensemble de nos informations en la
traitant différemment
euh alors ça ça je je répondrais V V
questions j'essayie d'être d'être de
vulgariser mais pour moi c'est essentiel
c'est essentiel c'est que décloisonner
le renseignement c'est nous permettre
effectivement de mille notre action
notre action opérationnelle de gendarme
et l'action aussi de l'état très
clairement parce que dans les
territoires ultramarins dans vos
territoire dans nos territoires euh il
vous aura pas échappé que ce que l'on
traite sur le plan judiciaire a des
liens forcément une porosité avec ce
qu'on traite en matière d'ordre public
bien évidemment donc moi je je je je là
je vise à avoir une approche globale et
d'ailleurs ce que je vous donne comme
approche là ça fait 1 an que
j'évangélise partout c'est le cas de
dire les territoir ultramarin et les
autorit
préfait autorité judiciaire et qui sont
qui sont pleinement dans cet objectif là
et le but dans tout ça c'est de
permettre à l'État ça répond à votre
question de mieux cibler son action de
mieux cibler parce qu' moment donné on
peut pas tout faire donc et donc là à un
moment donné c'est dire voilà on est
confronté par exemple ben je exemple en
nouvellecédonie à une vraie
problématique de il y a les violen
familiales certes mais une problématique
de stupéfiant et notamment de production
locale et là c'est là c'est vraie
priorité par exemple pour la Calédonie
c'est c'est un exemple et là on va
mettre le paquet
dessus et le trè axe d'effort c'est le
renforcement de la coopération
internationale de
proximité parce que on ne peut pas comme
je disais on peut pas traiter les
phénomène qu'on essaie de cartographier
je répondais deè AX d'effort sans les
traiter avec nos partenaires quand on
est à Saint-Martin on on est
interdépendant de la partie néerlandaise
bien évidemment quand on est en Guyane
on est obligé de parler de plateau des
Guyanes on sait très bien que leur
payage illégal bien on a si je
caricature on a les garim peros 8000 à
peu près qui arrivent du Brésil le
matériel la logistique et dont le
mercure arrive du Surinam et puis l'or
repart vers Surinam pour partir sur le
marché parallèle de l'or à
Dubaï c'est les grandes les grands flux
ça c'est donc on ne peut pas là j'en
parlais encore tout à l'heure avec avec
le monsieur Joram le conseiller de la du
Premier ministre pour pour les outr
mères à un moment donné bon je pense que
prochainement il risque y avoir un
déplacement de très haut niveau en
Guyane très clairement faut qu'on avance
faut qu' faut qu'on avanceut qu'on soit
plus fort avec nos plus plus coordonnés
avec nos partenaires brésiliens par
exemple les Brésiliens je je prends cet
exemple là mais ont des programmes de
traçabilité de l'or ont des programmes
de de surveillance satellitaire des
sites d'orpaillage illégaux
euh où par exemple il dédent euh ils ont
un contrat avec avec euh avec les
satellites Starlink avec Elon Musk pour
justement avoir avoir des passages
réguliers et voir l'évolution de leur
site
euh on ne peut pas faire de patrouille
pour l'instant on peut pas faire de
patrouille armée avec nos camarades
brésiliens de part et d'autre de la
frontière c'est pas possible
al vous me direz c'est bizarre on est en
2024 mais parce que l'arrangement ce
qu'on appelle un arrangement
intergouvernemental ne le prévoit pas
donc il faut qu'on aille sur un nouvel
AIG donc ça c'est ça c'est un vrai
livrable à la fois politique et
opérationnel c'est essentiel les Garos
donc je pense exemple là les Garos
savent très bien qu'à la frontière quand
il passent en France il y a plus de
brésilien et quand il passe au Brésil il
y a plus de français donc c'est comme
quand on passe de département entre
département dans l'Hexagone
et donc il faut être capable
effectivement d'avoir une approche
globale avec nos camarades brésiliens et
ça c'est essentiel sur le plan sur le
plan opérationnel donc voilà trois axe
d'effort pour moi qui sont essentiels ça
sert à rien de d'en avoir 10 ou 10 ou 12
donc l'empreinte territoriale le lien
avec la population la proximité le lien
avec les élus avec vous avec les élus de
terrain c'est essentiel hein c'est pour
ça que tout à l'heure j'étais avec nos
camarades de de laacédom qui c'est c'est
ce sont des relais qui sont vraiment
essentiels pour dans lest ultramarin les
actions innovante notamment l'approche
l'approche de convergence du
renseignement et l'approche globale et
la coopération internationale de
proximité voilà excusez-moi j'étais un
petit peu long mais les outremèes ben
requierèrent enfin requierrent de ma
part et puis l'ensemble de mes équipe
ave de mes gendarmes parce que je suis
pas tout seul bien évidemment requier
une grande attention et bon j'en parle
aussi bah je pense que j'en parle aussi
avec passion quelque part parce que Ben
bah je suis dans le même bateau que vous
hein parce que on souhaite faire faire
en sorte que ça se passe mieux pour nos
nos nos concitoyens nos concitoyennes
dans nos différents territoires je vous
remercie merci général pour vos propos
qui ont
été très clairs et qui rejoint les
préoccupations de de mon nombre de
personnes autour de cette table je vais
laisser la parole à notre rapporteur
Philippe B pour poursuivre
l'audition alors je n'ai pas de nouvelle
de sin Lurel donc il n'a pas pu donc
Philippe tu auras là vous
aurez vous n'avez pas été trop long au
contraire c'était très intéressant
et en
effet la passion que vous
avez eu dans dans l'exposé de de cette
situation nous l'avons bien ressenti et
nous la partageons je ne suis pas un
très grand spécialiste des problèmes de
sécurité outreemère mais j'ai pu quand
même les observer notamment en Guyane et
j'ai vu à l'œuvre plusieurs fois les
gendarmes de Guyane à Marie passoula à
canopi je crois que c'est la police qui
est à Saint-Laurent du Maroni ou ce sont
aussi les gendarmes c'est les gendarmes
en fait il la la police non c'était bien
les gendarmes j'ai patrouillé avec eux à
Saint-Laurent du Maroni la nuit et j'ai
bien vu
la particularité des des risques qui
auquel ils sont ils sont confrontés et
la difficulté de leur de leur tâches
ayant même assisté à des interpellations
d'ailleurs qui n qui n'ont pas abouti
les gens sétant jeté à l'eau en
traversant un Marat et en abandonnant
les l'objet de leur forfait mais
enfin quand quand on va à
canopi on ne voit
pas le gendarme du monde rural on voit
le soldat
on voit le légionnaire pratiquement euh
on voit les conditions de vie
euh et on voit les preuves qu'il
subissent et on a envie d'exprimer notre
reconnaissance c'est là que la diversité
de la
gendarmerie saute le plus aux yeux euh
vous avez des cité des chiffres de
criminalité et de
délinquence qui sont absolument
frappants et qui justifi de notre part
euh de nous appliquer à vous aider euh
parce que votre mission c'est de ne pas
abandonner nos compatriotes d'outrem qui
sont exposés à ces dangers je suppose
que
dans cet état des lieux euh si on
recherche l'analyse des causes il y a
des causes peut-être
endogènes mais aussi des causes exogènes
et quand vous approfondissez la question
et que vous évoquez les relations avec
le Brésil ou le Surinam s'agissant de la
Guyane on voit bien que le le contexte
international sur lequel vous êtes
revenu plusieurs fois de l'action de la
gendarmerie dans certains de nos entre
de nos autres mères au moins euh compte
pour beaucoup les méthodes de travail
euh euh les règles de procédure pénal ne
sont pas les mêmes partout et puis il
faut dire les chose on n'est pas sur
Internet là euh madame la Présidente si
est rransmis ah on est retransmis sur
Internet oui parce que j'hésite à porter
des appréciations sur les régimes
voisins euh de de la France outreem mais
il y a un certain nombre de régimes euh
dont euh euh
les méthodes de travail ne sont pas les
nôtres et
certains certains des des certaines des
organisations criminelles ne sont pas
sans lien avec ces régimes eux même dans
certains cas je n'irai pas plus loin la
recherche de coopération plus grande ne
tient évidemment compte de cette de
cette
difficulté je remarque aussi
que vous avez parlé de décloisonner le
renseignement il y a pas seulement le
décloisonnement du renseignement parfois
il y a la nécessité entre la gendarmerie
et d'autres armes très présentes et qui
jouent un rôle
important dans le le contrôle des
frontières ou ou dans la surveillance
des activités
illicites dans la forêt vierge notamment
leur
paillage il y a parfois aussi des
problèmes de coordination et de
coopération est-ce que vous pourriez
nous nous dire si vous ressentez cela et
s'il y a des améliorations à
obtenir un un militaire d'une autre arme
que la gendarmerie ne peut pas avoir de
mission d'officier de police judiciaire
mais peut constater pourtant l'existence
de délit en absence même de gendarmes et
rendre impossible les poursuites puisque
il n'a pas les moyens juridiques euh de
les de les mettre en œuvre j'aimerais
bien avoir votre vision pas simplement
puisque vous avez abordé largement ce
point sur les moyens en terme de
ressources humaines
[Musique]
d'immobilier d'organisation mais aussi
des aspects sensibles de relation
avec
avec d'autres armes pour rendre plus
plus efficace les les poursuites et puis
d'une manre manière générale à partir de
de cette réflexion est-ce qu'il y a de
votre point de
vue des
adaptations dans le code de procédure
pénale
à à à mettre en
œuvre faisant appel au législateur bien
sûr la Constitution nous permet de faire
des adaptations pour rendre plus
efficace votre action
outreem pour ne pas rester face à ces
chiffres
submergés par cette criminalité et cette
délinquence dont je disais qu'elle était
en partie endogène mais certainement en
partie en partie
exogène alors ce sont plus ce sont en
partie des observations et en partie des
questions que que que je vous pose mais
c'est l'orientation de notre travail
nous enons nous en avons délibéré avec
la présidente et victora
Lurel nous recher ch des moyens y
compris juridiques et
législatifs de rendre plus efficace
l'action de l'État outre ma notamment
dans la lutte contre la délinquence et
l'immigration illicite et et dans
contrôle des
frontière monur le
ministre
alors
en matière de coordination et de et de
pouvoir donner aux armées on fait
référence là en fait le seul endroit la
seule zone où on travaille vraiment
manière totalement
interopérable avec les armées sur le
plan opérationnel c'est la Guyane dans
tous les
autres on est sur une notion de moyens
d'appui d'érosransport de soutien
logistique voilà et et très clairement
je vais évacuer les autres territoires
parce que on n pas spécifique c'est
spécifique à la Guan mais les autres
territoire mais c'est très important les
armées sont là et je reviens sur
l'équipe France enfin pour moi la notion
d'équipe France avec le préfet le
procureur le procureur général les chef
interservice y compris le les comsup les
com des forces ciel et donc là là moi je
je à chaque fois je je je n'ai qu'à me
louer effectivement bah de de l'appui de
soutien euh notamment sur le plan
logistique des des armées en particulier
euh et pour votre information euh bon on
se conforme aux règles effectivement de
ce qu'ont mis en place les armées je
rappelle que les armées interviennent en
fait prêtent leur concours en matière
d'appui de
soutien selon la règle ce qu'on appelle
la règle des 4i hein c'est lorsque nos
moyens par exemple sont indisponibleson
a pas on n pas les moyens lorsqu'ils ne
sont pas adaptés à la situation
lorsqu'ils sont insuffisant et voire
inexistant en fait quand quand l'analyse
abouti à cocher toutes ces cases
effectivement
ben effectivement nous soutiennent et
nous
appu indisponible inadapté insuffisant
inexistant c'est la règle des
qui et ça se passe très bien outreemè et
je dirais cette règle des 4i outre mer
et même beaucoup plus souple dans les
dans les ta ultramarin parce que
effectivement on revient on revient don
je parlais au départ l'éloignement on
est loin donc on est ensemble voilà donc
on met à profit les moyens certes on
rend compte à Paris à l'étatmajor des
armées mais c'est plus souple dans les
teritire Ultra mararin la partie
opérationnelle c'est vraiment la Guyane
et c'est c'est vrai que moi j'ai coutume
de dire quand je parle de la Guyane et
de maotte
aussi qu'on a une gendarmerie un état
qui est en opération
permanente et je dis pas ça pour faire
peur c'est la réalité ça veut pas dire
que c'est la crise c'est la crise c'est
encore le degré au-dessus on est en
opération permanente ça veut dire que il
n'y a pas de temps
faible et l'opération permanente se
concrétise notamment en guyan
par c'est l'opération une opération donc
je rappelle qui est député en 2008 hein
et cette opération harpi et bien c'est
euh une opération qui vise à lutter
contre leur payage
illégal selon quatre euh volets quatre
pilier il y a le pilier sécurité donc ça
c'est avec les forces armées guyanaises
et la gendarmerie sur lequel je vais
revenir par rapport
à c'est le volet social c'est le volet
diplomatique et c'est le volet
économique donc l'opération RP est une
opération inter
ministériel avec un pilier important
c'est le pilier
sécurité et dans le cadre de pili
sécurité au moment où je vous parle en
jungle engager systématiquement 250
militaires des forces armées
guillanaises et 150 gendarmes
en permanence en
permanence et pourquoi les gendarmes les
gendarmes en fait ce sont des gendarmes
qui sont mobiles
donc ça rejoint sur les escadrons
déplacés je parlais tout à 500 gendarmes
ça fait 21 escadrons aremè et sur les 21
escadrons il y en a six qui sont
anguyan et sur les six anguyanes il y en
a deux qui sont sont consacrés en
permanence à la lutte contre leur
paayage
illégal donc ça fait à peu près 150 et
150 en fait c'est eux qui assurent ils
ont une fonction d'OPJ et c'est eux
qui le la la déclinaison de l'activité
judiciaire au plus profond dans la
jungle et ça vous direz que ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne bien ça
fonctionne bien la question s'est posée
effectivement c'est très intéressant ce
que la la question s'est posée de savoir
si euh on ne pouvait pas aller vers une
une forme d'autonomie effectivement des
des forces armées euh on l'a vite éludé
parce que notre
systèmeable et c'est pas forcément une
question de moyen pour nous et c'est
très et c'est très et je dirais
et c'est très efficace je vais vous dire
pourquoi et je vous donne un exemple
c'est très efficace
euh sur le plan judiciaire que tout soit
acté sur le plan judiciaire par des
officiers de police judiciire par
exemple à chaque fois qu'il y a des des
interpell tion d'urgau des destructions
de
matériel prise par exemple on récupère
des téléphones
portables et donc là par exemple à
chaque fois il y y a une procédure qui
est ouverte cette procédure dans le cas
cette procédure on saisit le matériel je
exemple du téléphone portable on a une
procédure nous où on conditionne le
matériel parce que c'est très humide on
conditionne et dès que la mission en
jungle est finie ça peut être 2 jours 3
jours 3 semaines en fait ce
vont à Cayen et à Cayen on a
industrialisé l'exploitation des
téléphones c'est le déblocage des
téléphones et l'analyse des téléphones
et la mise dans des bases de données
sérielles donc on revient sur la sur
l'exploitation des données de masse dont
je parlais tout à l'heure avec le
décoisonnement du renseignement et ces
données de masse sont mis en des bases
des bases
judiciaires et
en de discriminer à partir de mots clés
on a des visages on a des des numéros et
cetera ça nous permet de mettre en
lumière des relations entre
personnes donc ça c'est judiciarisé et
c'est ça incrémente des bases
judiciaires et ce qui est le plus
intéressant c'est je vais au bout du
bout très intéressant c'est que ces
bases judiciaires elles sont utilisé sur
directive du sur du procureur de la
République
afin d'incrémenter l'étatmajor interarmé
et l'étatmajor gendarmerie de harpi dans
le cadre de la analyse du renseignement
et du ciblage c'est qu'en fait ces
données là sont utilisées aussi sur le
plan judiciaire mais elles sont aussi
utilisées pour certaines à des fins
opérationnelles c'est a un état majeur
en fait harp un état majeur des armées
il un état majur gendarmerie la DEP en
fait on a une C de renseignement qui qui
est
conjointe ce qui est une première on a
une renseignement qui est conjointe les
armées et la gendarmerie ne sont plus
seulement colocalisé en matière de
renseignement mais travaill
ensemble et les dossiers moi je vois les
dossiers les les notes hebdomadaires sur
les ciblages les priorités en matière de
contreage illégal et le ciblage et de
objectifs de certains sites que j'ai
encore vu hier c'est
remarquable parce qu'en fait en fait on
arrive à déclisonner ce renseignement là
à l'utiliser à l'exploiter pas seulement
à des fins judiciaires mais des fins
opérationneles et et vraiment c'est le
but rechercher moi ce que je recherche
dans tous les territoire ultarin voilà
j'ai un peu débordé mais pour moi enfin
cette ce cheminement est important à
vous expliquer
parce que ce qu'on récupère en jungle
oui il y a des avoirs criminels mais il
y a des des y a des informations en fait
qui sont utilisées à des fins
judiciaires et
utilisé mais c'est très c'est assez
vertueux même c'est très vertueux et je
pense que là on a mis ça en place assez
récemment tout ce que je vous dis on est
mis on a mis ça en place prier semestre
2023 et on commence à ça commence à voir
ses effets très
clairement donc donc oui c'est c'est
efficace après après on peut toujours
faire faire plus je rappelle que la
Guyane c'est quand même l'équivalent du
Portugal géographiquement c'est c'est
important de l'avoir en
tête est-ce qu'il est est-ce que il
serait nécessaire effectivement ah
pardon
c'est ça marchait pas ah
pardon est-ce qu'il est est-ce qu'il est
nécessaire effectivement quelles
adaptations
oui il y a besoin d'adaptation bien
évidemment euh le le le code de
procédure pénale ne ne peut pas
s'appliquer de la même manière partout
euh entre l'hexagone et certains
territoires ultra c'est pas possible
euh par exemple dans les prochains mois
euh on aura l'obligation de la présence
d'un avocat lors des gardes à
vu ça va entrer en
vigueur oui ça va être simple
à grand senti c'est très simple
et donc
effec oui c'est ça exactement exactement
et donc moi je pense que alors ça on l'
on nous on l'a fait remonter au niveau
de la de la gendarmerie au niveau du
ministre de l'intérieur mais ça moi je
vous en parle je pense qu'il serait il
est nécessaire effectivement d'avoir une
exception de de de cette obligation de
de l'avocat dans les gardes à vu euh
pour les territoires où il y a des
unités des territoires isolés mais c'est
pas que la an c'est d'autres territoir
parce qu'à un moment donné c'est pas
possible parce que si l'avocat peut pas
se projeter je dire il y a pas de garde
à vue donc pas de mise en cause enfin
c'est je veux dire là là là pour le coup
la la le procès pénal ne peut pas ne
peut pas vraiment être efficace donc je
pense qu'il y a une vraie réflexion à
avoir donc on l'a déjà mené on l'a porté
mais moi je vous la livre effectivement
d'exemption de l'obligation de la
présence d'un avocat euh tout de suite
en
fait
en guyan par exemple je vous donne un
exemple on a un
report de de 20h de garde à vue pour les
infractions qui rentrent dans le cadre
de leur paayage illégal c'est en rapport
avec le code
minier mais pour les autres
infractions en fait on n pas de report
de guarde à
vu ça vrai sujet parce que les gens faut
les sortir de la jungle
dans le cadre du traitement des
étrangers en situation régulière en
forêt parce que quand on interpelle
forcément certain nombre qui sont
situation
régulière le report automatique de 20h
pour la retenue vérification du droit à
l'instar de ce qui est fait pour la
garde à vue sur le plan judiciaire ça
existe
pas donc vous imaginez bien les
conséquences un moment donné
dans le contrôle de nos
frontières on a on a on a on a
effectivement des vulnérabilités ou des
plutôt en regardant positivement il y a
des aménagements je pense à à proposer
en fait il y a uniquement le code minier
qui permet effectivement ce report de
20h de garde à vue pour les personnes
qui sont interpellé en flagrant délit
d'orpaillage
illégal par exemple autre autre code
figure
en
Nouvelle-Calédonie en Polynésie il y a
un code de la route alors change de
sujet mais aussi un code c'est il y a un
code de la route qui est qui est propre
voilà c'est pas le même code de la route
voilà et donc et donc c'est c'est c'est
pas trop favorable à notre action pardon
ou au
milieu euh par exemple les routes
calédoniennes il y a des portions à à
110 kmh là où dans dans l'Hexagone
certaines ces mêmes portions ser limité
à 70 km/h alors je pas stigmatiser un
cadonier monsieur le
sénateur
mais ça change pas le niveau autorisé de
vitesse sauf que je parle de
on parle de sécurité routière de côte de
la route mais il faut savoir que sur des
territoires comme la Polynésie
ou la nouvellecédonie je veux dire un
des un un un des mots endémiques c'est
quand même la lutte contre la sécurité
routière c'est que par exemple quand on
vous parlez tiens Polynésie à quoi mon
Général pensez-vous quand vous on parle
Polynésie bah je parle Polynésie je dis
c'est beau la Polynésie certes euh c'est
très accueillant comme tous les
territoires ultramarins mais en matière
de sécurité ben on pense violence
intrafamiliale on pense sécurité
routière et on pense
stupéfiant c'est ça la
Polynésie mais
je
he c'est une réalité c'est une réalité
c'est
c'est si on fait des des on fait une
cartographie à grosse maille c'est ça
donc oui sécurité routière est
fondamentale et quand on connaît par
exemple on voit les routes il y a pas
beaucoup de routes c'est pas comme si on
avait des réseaux routiers qui étaient
très très
denses on voit très bien quand on va
quand on prend l'île de Tahiti et qu'on
va sur le
site de la de la très belle épreuve de
surf à laquelle on vous allez assister
au mois d'août prochain lors des Joos et
bien on est sur un c'est une seule route
fait littitoral et on avit un cul de sac
quand
même mais oui mais et malgré ça on a des
problèmes de sécurité
routière donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
c'est un vrai sujet le la nouvelle qui
Doni pareil c'est violence
conjugale sécurité routière stupéfiant
c'est c'est c'est les mêmes les mêmes je
les mêmes agrégats que moi je j'ai en
tête voilà donc oui les adaptations
adaptation après il y a il y a une autre
adaptation c'est l'adaptation aussi
ial j'en ai parlé il y a pas longtemps
j'ai été convi intervenir par le
directeur des affaires criminelles et
des
grass un séminaire qui réunissait
c'était une première c'était très bien
les procureurs généraux des territoires
ultramarins très intéressant donc là on
est quand même sur procureurs généraux
c'est ceux qui qui délivrent la
politique pénale au
procureur bah moi je disais
qu'effectivement un des aspects que que
je mettais en avant c'était l'
importance effectivement que l'État on
revient sur la dataption de l'État le
thème de votre étude qu'on soit bien
synchrone avec la justice et que quand
on quand on se rapproche de la
population que la justice également
fasse de même je prends l'exemple de
concrètement de saint-bartelémie
Saint-Martin ben on va créer une
préfecture de plein exercice on a un
commandement ger plein exercice mais on
a que deux magistrats qui dépendent de
Baster que deux vice-procureurs qui
dépendent de bter on n pas encore de
tribunal judiciaire et on n pas de
maison
d'arrêt et la problématique une des
problématiques aussi mais ça je pense
que vous quand vous entendrez d'autres
personnes une des problématiques c'est
en bout de chaîne en matière de sécurité
c'est la problématique de la
surpopulation carcéral il y a une vraie
problématique de gestion des flux sur le
plan
carcéral donc là on est sur toute la le
procès pénal de de
l'interprélation jusqu'à effectivement
ben la mesure privative de de
liberté
donc voilà ce que j'ai j'ai répondu
j'étais un peu long à répondre mais
voilà c'est
c'est je pense que ces adaptations par
exemple en matière de garde à vue sont
essentielles je je moi j'insiste
vraiment dessus c'est que quand on va en
jungle vous connaissez la jungle quand
on va en jungle quand on interpelle des
gens ben il faut pouvoir ben mettre en
œuvre ben le code de procéure pénale et
on peut pas avoir le on peut pas avoir
l'avocat tout de suite c'est c'est pas
possible en jungle c'est puis à un
moment donné pour prendre une garde à
vue euh qui soit pas dans le cadre de la
page illégal la prendre dans un bureau
bien mais pour que la personne aussi a
tous ses droits aussi hein bien
évidemment bah il faut un petit peu de
délai pour la sortir de la jungle d'où
ce report de garde à vue enfin enfin ça
semble
évident mais moi je je je l'appelle de
mes vœux
effectivement merci je vais laisser la
parole à notre collègue anque Pétrus
merci madame la Présidente mon général
vous l'avez dit le 13 janvier vous
avez procédé
à on va dire la le lancement de la
création du commandement autonome de la
gendarmerie de Saint-Martin et
saint-bartelemi alors juste avant nous
avions reçu l'information qu'une brigade
mobile de proximité allait être installé
dans un des quartiers de de Saint-Martin
et précisément le quartier de
sandigan nous avons accueilli ces
dotations avec une très grande
satisfaction puisqu'elle répondait à
deux besoins au niveau de notre
territoire le premier est la
sécurisation du du territoire hein et
faire descendre les chiffres de la
délinquence que vous avez exposé tout à
l'heure et le 2èe besoin euh c'est ce
besoin d'autonomie qui correspond à
notre statut de collectivité à part
entière et qui nous permet si vous
voulez de de de prendre toutes nos
responsabilités dans ce domaine làà au
niveau du territoire donc nous ne
pouvons être que très satisfaits euh
cependant et là aussi vous vous avez
fait allusion aux voisins que nous avons
et que nous ne pouvons pas ignorer
Saint-Martin est particulièrement cons
puisque nous avons voisin sur le même
territoire que nous et seul une
frontière euh on va dire une frontière
dématérialisée nous nous sépare donc
effectivement il y a eu déjà un début de
relation avec la le côté hollandais de
lîle qui a qui porte des fruits ma
question serait est-ce qu'il est prévu
une accentuation de cette coopération
régionale que nous avons besoin au
niveau de la délinquence de notre
territoire enfin oui de notre territoire
puisque c'est un seul
oui absolument c'est c'est c'est c'est
prévu après il y a ce qui est visible et
ce qui est moins visible ce qui est
moins
visible c'est qu'en fait en matière de
en matière de renseignement sur le plan
judicière en
particulier on a la section de recherche
de Saint-Martin qui euh qui est dans un
un cercle
euh de de de servicees partenairire
étranger où ils échangent vraiment très
très bien ça va jusque ça va jusqu'au
FBI américain il y a pas simplement les
les les îles à côté mais il y a ça va
jusqu'aux Amériques donc ça ça échange
très très bien
euh après c'est c'est vrai qu'on avait
parlé avec le préfet mais c'est une une
idée qu'on peut avoir en tête et qu'on
effectivement qu'on qu'on pourrait avoir
ir en tête qu'on aura forcément en tête
dans les prochaines années c'est
pourquoi pas un centre de coopération
policière et douignère entre cine Martin
et la partie nairandaise et la partie
française mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant je dirais moi pour ce que je
constate le le le travail est est quand
même bien fait après vous vous le savez
très bien que il y a les policiers de
cine Martine sont assez particuliers on
va dire je m'étendrai pas forcément
dessus ils ont une approche très
particulière même en étant mentoré par
nos camarades parce qu'ils sont quand
même mentorés par les camarad de la
maré-chaussée royale néerlandaise c'est
qu'une par particularité je sais pas si
vous le savez mais effectivement ce
n'est plus une colonie néerlandaise bien
évidemment mais il y a toujours une
forte
présence batave qu'on dit sur sur le
territoire de C Martine et la Marie la
marie-chaussée royale néerlandaise est
très présente mais malgré ça
effectivement euh on a des bonnes
relations mais on peut faire mieux oui
je suis d'accord avec vous et c'est on
va on va chercher à le
renforcer merci euh George
naturel merci madame la Présidente mon
Général donc merci pour ces
présentations euh complète hein euh
effectivement de l'organisation euh la
gendarmerie autreemè alors des
spécificités vous en avez parlé euh nos
territoire du passé a une particularité
c'est qu'effectivement les compétences
sont pas les mêmes que dans les
départements et et là je veux dire vous
parlez de l'équipe France mais l'équipe
France doit être élargie aussi par des
problèmes de répartition de compétences
on par vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
sécurité routière c'est sûr que la
sécurité routière s'il y a pas j'allais
dire un un travail collectif entre les
compétences de la Nouvelle Calédonie par
exemple voir des communes et j'aborderai
aussi le sujet des communes parce que je
suis convainc c pour l'avoir pratiqué
pendant 15 ans dans une commune
limitrophe de la capitale euh le
partenariat entre la gendarmerie et les
autres collectivités et les communes en
particulier pour ceux qui ont des
polices municipales je pense qu'elle est
essentiel hein dans dans ce qu'on veut
accompagner et traiter on parlait de
délinquence tout à l'heure mais ça fait
partie effectivement des des des sujets
essentiels euh je vais pas m'étendre sur
les moyens parce que effectivement bon
j'aur aussi des questions mais bon vous
en avez parlé je suis sûr qu'on a on a
toujours les uns et les autres des
demandes pour augmenter nos moyens
qu'ell soi en personnel ou ou en en
équipement alors je pense que un de mes
collègues va être satisfait puisqueil y
a une nouvelle gendarmerie qui va être
reconstruite je pense à mon collègue de
moinsoux qui l' appelé de ses vœux
depuis depuis pas mal de temps le
président de la République lors de son
passage lui a promis donc je sais que
c'est ça y est c'est officiel
euh la rénovation des des cas erme aussi
vous en avez parlé un petit peu dans
votre est importante et puis je peux
donner l'exemple de ce que bah j'ai mis
quand même pas loin d'une dizaine
d'années pour le faire pour reconstruire
une caserne commune de dber où il a on a
on a imaginé un système particulier de
de de séparer la partie logement qui est
gérée par un opérateur social qui sait
faire on en immobilier on n'est pas tous
des spécialistes c'est important et la
partie technique j'illeur financer en
partenariat avec l'État et et la commune
du reste cet exemple là il va être servi
pour d'autres casernes je crois qu'il y
en a une à la fois qui va être
construite à bourrail et ailleurs en
bref je crois que ce que je voulais dire
là c'est que on ne peut que se
satisfaire hein de du partenariat qu'on
avec la gendarmie en Nouvelle-Calédonie
puisque après le seul le seul endroit où
il y a une police nationale c'est dans
la capitale à nou moi ma question elle
va être un petit peu spécifique
aujourd'hui euh et et et je et là je
j'allais dire j'apporte l'inquiétude de
d'un certain nombre de de mes
collègues les jeux les Jeux Olympique
approche parlé pour Tahiti tout à
l'heure on sait très bien qu'il va
falloir avoir des effectifs importants
du reste on aborde nous un problème de
sécurité dans les transports au Sénat et
notre inquiétude c'est effectivement
qu'il a des moyens aujourd'hui qui sont
chez nous dans les outres mers qu'on va
devoir
rapatrierin au niveau national et à
Paris en particulier
en Nouvelle-Calédonie on a peut-être une
année aussi un peu spécifique au niveau
avenir institutionnel au niveau des
crises dans dans le dans le nickel donc
je il va falloir être vigilant he pour
que ces moyens éventuellement hein qu'on
rapatrie dans
l'Hexagone puisse être à un moment donné
apporté il peut y avoir aussi et on l'a
vu à la réunion des des des des
événements climatiques qui demande la
présence de gendarmerie donc voilà
comment comment enfin si ça déjà étéé je
suppose comment équilibrer voilà les les
équipes entre le rapatriment d'effectifs
pour les Jeux Olympiques à Paris et
j'allais dire être prêt à pouvoir
projeter des effectifs dans nos
territoires d'autr m voilà ma
question la présidente mon Général moi
je voudrais tout d'abord je suis
sénateur de
maotte dans un premier temps remercier
les forces de gendarmerie à Mayotte qui
faut un travail difficile mais un
travail je dirais formidable dans un
environnement que vous savez que tout le
monde sait très très très difficile dans
un contexte aussi sécuritaire très
dégradé vous avez bien sûr des bons
rapports avec la population on le voit
on le sait avec avec les élus aussi ça
se passe très très bien mais bien sûr il
y a des vous avez dit tout à l'heure là
sur l'adaptation de la gendarmerie c'est
sa capacité de s'adapter et je c'est une
boutade peut-être que il faudrait aussi
que l'ensemble des services de l'État
aussi fasse comme vous s'adapter aussi
chez nous aussi je pense que ce serait
quand même une bonne chose pour nos pour
nos territoires alors moi j'ai que
quelques questions et euh et par rapport
à ce qu' a dit le président
sur la procédure les procédures que vous
menez à Mayotte euh comment
on vous arrivez à à Menz vos travail
dans la mesure où 50 % de la population
est
étrangère 2e chose l'ensemble des
mineurs euh que vous interpellez n ni
référent
ni parents ni adresse et souvent c'est
eux qui qui s'aiment souvent la terreur
là-bas comment aussi faire votre travail
lorsque nous avons une prison de
magieavau qui fait 27 places avec 650
détenus
aujourd'hui c'est la réalité j'étais à
Mayotte il y a une semaine je suis allé
voir le procureur je suis allé visiter
la prison de magikavo c'est ça
c'est-à-dire il y a quatre détenus dans
une petite cellule
et et c'est vraiment difficile donc
c'est vrai que nous avons 650 détenus
sur une capacité de de78 euh
places à Mayotte aussi la justice telle
qu'elle est rendue euh il faut un
traducteur il faut un traducteur et
aujourd'hui euh on dit que le traducteur
doit être diplômé
euh de bac
plus mais les gens qui sont embauchés
pour lesê traducteur ils viennent que
quand il y a bien sûr des audiences donc
il arrive parfois que euh des procès
n'ont pas lieu parce qu'il y a pas de
traducteur le traducteur n'est pas là
donc on peut
pasenir le le procès euh autre chose
aussi assez spécifique chez nous là-bas
c'est vrai vous l'avez dit il manque d'
avocat il n'y a pas d'avocat maotte et
ceux qui étaient là la plupart sont
partis et dans ce contexte comment
évidemment lorsque vous avez fait votre
travail et c'est ce qu'on vous reproche
euh mon général amamaotte c'est que
souvent vous faites votre travail c'est
pas vous qu'on reproche c'est la justice
à maotte vous faites votre travail vous
interpellez bien sûr les délinquant sauf
que le lendemain on les voit tous dehors
ils sont tous dehors et et les gens se
disent
mais il vaut mieux peut-être se faire
justice soi-même parce que quand on
interpelle les gens et qu'on les amène
bien sûr devant la justice le lendemain
ils sont dehors parce que bien sûr ils
sont dehors parce que évidemment au vu
de ce que je viens de d'énumérer tout à
l'heure
alors comment alors Monsieur euh mon
Général
euh vous faites alors pour ne pas lâcher
à un moment donné
bien sûr parce que les gendarmes le
disent ils disent écoutez moi j'ai
interpellé le le jeune il y a 2h mais et
le le soir il est toujours là je
rattrape la même personne je le ramène
on le relâche voilà c'est un peu
compliqué mais surtout moi ma question
par rapport à ce que j'ai dit là c'est
sur l'opération bouchou que vous avez
évoqué vous n'avez pas voulu le nommer
moi je le nomme c'est l'opération bouch
alors quel enseignement en matière de
maintien de l'ordre sur le volet
judiciaire comme je l'ai dit vous tirez
de l'opération bouchou de l'année
dernière je sais que vous avez la
pratique de retour d'expérience
rettex et vos enseignements sont très
attendus alors moi ma question c'est
ça
alors si vous permettez merci beaucoup
pour ces questions si vous permettez je
vais revenir sur sur la question de la
sénatrice Petrus he parce que pour
compléter pendant ce temps mon mon
cerveau continue à travailler donc sur
sur la la partie sur la partie
internationale en
fait à la faveur de la création de de ce
nouveau command généralement
saint-mtinmis Saint-Martin on va créer
en plus de la brigade à Sandy Ground sur
laquelle je vais revenir on va créer
euh un poste d'officiers adjoint de
police judiciaire donc je parlais de
renseignement et quatre militaires
également en plus donc ça fera 5 qui
vont faire que de l'appuis judiciaire et
du renseignement ce qui n'existe pas à
saint-barteléi
Saint-Martin jusqu'alors donc et et ça
c'est très important à souligner et le
cet officier adjoint poli judiciire de
renseignement c'est ce ci qui va être en
charge au niveau du comjand justement en
propre de la partie coopération
internationale de proximité et vous
comprendrez effectivement que Madame
sénatrice effectivement c'était une
compagnie avant une compagnie ben ils
ont leur boulot de la compagnie et faire
avec les mêmes les effectifs de la
coopération internationale vraiment en
profondeur c'est un peu c'est un peu
délicat c'est c'est un peu le croix la
bannière là pour le coup il aura des
moyens dédiés en matière de pojudiciaire
de renseignement et c'est cet officier
là qui sera le référent et qui sera le
point de contact au niveau de la
coopération internationale de proximité
avec le côté néerlandais ça je vous
apporte cet élément parce que c'est
important donc ça veut dire que
forcément ben ça va doper un petit peu
cette bien évidemment cette cette cet
axe majeur et je souligne également pour
l'ensemble des
euh desessinatrices etessinateurs que
par exemple la brigade mobile c'est un
point trs important la brigade mobile de
S sigr c'est un quartier sensible hein
de de Saint-Martin je quand je dis
sensible je ne stigmatise pas du tout
hein c'est c'est un quartier très
sensible c'est un quartier sur lequel
nous avons échangé vous et moi madame la
sénatrice qui vous tient à cœur aussi ce
quartier et et cette brigade mobile en
fait s'insère dans un cadre plus global
d'approche à la fois de l'État et de la
collectivité pour justement permettre
effectivement aux concitoyens et aux
concitoyennes de s dan de pouvoir et
bien revivre quelque part ou vivre
normalement et en fait la brigade mobile
c'est pas juste une brigade comme ça
c'est une brigade ça s'insère dans un
ensemble d'action on en a parlé et c'est
par exemple l'éclairage public c'est on
refait les trottoirs
c'est un une
MJC c'est des choses c'est comme ça
c'est pas juste la brigade mobile donc
ça c'est très important à savoir donc
que la gendarmerie l'état sincère
effectivement fait une planification
avec les collectivités et là on est
vraiment dans l'équipe France
construction c'est ça c'est très
important donc ça je tenais à en parler
et particularité également on a sur
cette brigade là on va avoir un poste
commun avec la police territoriale qu'il
y aura pas une gendarmerie et une police
territoriale il y aura un même poste
avec de dents 10 policiers territoriaux
et 6
gendarmes donc on est vraiment sur une
mixité une approche mixte et conjointe
de la problématique de sécurité de ce
quartier là donc là on va vraiment là on
est vraiment sur sur quelque chose
d'innovant en matière effectivement
d'appropriation territoriale par l'État
et par la GIE en
particulier sur les Jeux
Olympiques oui le Paris va capter
beaucoup de capacités
euh actuellement on a 21 escadrons de
gendarmerie qui sont déployés autremè il
y en aura moins qui seront déployés il y
en aura moins cet été il y a des
ponctions qui vont être faites
mais je dis bien des ponctions ça veut
dire que
euh le le ministre de l'Intérieur va
faire en sorte de ponctionner le moins
possible durant juste le temps
nécessaire certains escadrons qui sont
nécessaires à la sécurité des Jeux
Olympiques sur Paris concrètement ça
veut dire que par exemple en Calédonie
il y en aura il y en aura un en moins
sur de territoires il y en aura
également
euh comment on va compenser ça euh on va
le compenser de deux manières la
première il y aura un taux de
permissionnaire ce qui était annoncé en
interne gendarmerie et décidé par le M
deintérieur un taux de permissionnaire
beaucoup moins important parce que
l'effort des JO est un effort collectif
c'est pas seulement un effort hexagonal
c'est un effort de l'ensemble du
pays donc au lieu d'avoir concrètement
au lieu d'avoir 33 % de permissionnaire
on en aura maximum 20 voilà en
gendarmerie et également on va combler
deuxième chose on va combler par des
réservistes moi par exemple pour les
territoires ultramarins j'ai d'ors et
déjà le budget nécessaire pour pouvoir
engager de manière pleine et entière des
réservistes sur l'ensemble des
territoire et en particulier sur
ceux de parmi lesquels il y aura une
ponction justement de de de Gen mobile
donc quand on fait le calcul finalement
moi je l'ai fait en matière de
planification à la la fois d'un taux de
permissionnaire réduit plus d'un apport
conséquent de réserviste on sera on sera
quasiment à l'étal c'est pas la même
capacité en matière d'ordre public mais
en matière de présence terrain on est
sur la même notion de présence terrain
je donne l' exemple concret aussi de la
Polynésie française en Polynésie
française on sait très bien bien qui est
l'épreuve des Jeux Olympiques il y aura
pas de de genre mobile en plus mais ça
on l'a déjà anticipé depuis plus d'un an
et on l' anticipé comment en doublant
notre capacité de réserviste on était
jusqu'à il y a un an il y avait en gros
100 réservistes là on a une dernière
classe qui se forme actuellement on va
passer à plus de 200 c'est le contrat ce
qui permet en
fait de
per effectivement ce ce ce nonengagement
de G mobile mais en Polynésie pour la
sécurité des j c'est pas du gendarm
mobile dont on a besoin c'est c'est de
sécurité je dirais du quotidien c'est
pas de l'ordre public et là je pense que
l'approche est bonne c'est l'approche de
dire et bien la sécurité des Jos en
Polynésie sera assuré surtout par des
par des par des Polynésiens qui sont
réservistes donc ça sera aussi une
acceptabilité qui sera plus importante
nous le pensons et en plus on va
renforcer aussi avec des réservis de la
Nouvelle Calédonie parce qu'on forme
plus de réservices en Calédonie donc on
fera des renforts également faire on va
faire une trentaine de réservices qui
vont qui vont partir de la Calédonie qui
vont renforcer les camarades dans le
Pacifique donc intra intrapacifique
voilà donc en fait globalement ça va ça
va ça va s'équilibrer hein très
clairement moi je ne suis pas je ne suis
pas très inquiet je ne suis pas très
inquiet mais là ça sera ça sera une
ponction vraiment pour les gios il y a
les gios et puis n'oublions pas il y a
les Jos mais n'oublions pas les
paralympiques parce que on focalise sur
les Jio juilletaoût mais les les menaces
et le besoin de sécurité sont aussi sur
les sur les les paralympiques bien
évidemment monsieur le sénateur sur
Mayot
sujet
d'importance euh alors justement ce que
je dis sujet d'importance alors je vais
me permettre une petite digression
pourer du général au particulier moi
quand j'ai pris mon poste on m'a donné
des priorités bien évident comme dans
chaque poste hein et mes deux priorités
territoriales sont Mayotte et la Guyane
et quand et et et et quand je dis ça ça
veut pas dire pour autant et ça je
l'explique à l'ensemble des des élus des
des gendarmes quand je me déplace ça
veut pas dire pour autant qu'on délaisse
les autres territoires bien évidemment
donc on porte une attention à tous les
territoires mais à un moment donné on va
appliquer des priorités capacitaires
qu'on va faire en plus bien évidemment
sur Mayotte et la
guillane et j'ai coutume de dire aussi
quand je me déplace que une des
manifestations de de ne pas délaisser
les territoires moi ce se manifeste par
un une décision simple de ma part j'ai
dans mes mains les ressources humaines
ça les 3900 officiers sous-officiers
notamment les
sous-officiers c'est à mon niveau qu'il
y a des mutations un choix appel à
volontaire et mutation et bien là
l'année 2023 tous les postes budgétaires
sont comblés tous les postes budgétaires
sont
comblés j'ai juste se se postes en moins
mais c'est même pas des postes de
terrain donc c'est sur les
3900 il y a aucun poste de terrain qui
n'est pas
comblé donc je suis d'autant plus euh
euh ça ça ça montre effectivement ben
qu'on met pas la priorité que sur Guyane
Mayot en matière de ressources humaines
mais tous les territoires effectivement
aucun n'est délaissé et ça c'est
important de le manifester
ça monsieur le sénateur je pourrais pas
répondre à toutes vos questions vous
imaginez bieness au mais je préfère
commencer par
là je peux pas je peux difficilement me
prononcer sur la surpopulation carcérale
c'est une réalité c'est une réalité mais
la solution c'est pas la G qu' qu'
l' dis aussi oui tout à fait tout à fait
mais c'est un fait c'est un fait on a un
taux de 240
% 240 % à maotte à la prison de magicavo
et ce n'est pas le seul territoire
ultramarin où c'est comme
ça ne stigmatisons pas maot parce que
c'est c'est c'est il n a pas que Mayotte
c'est un vrai
sujet c'est le cas no kéonie c'est le en
général nous avons bien perçu et chers
collègues l'importance de cette question
et nous allons faire quelques
déplacements et même de nombreux
déplacements outre mer et nous irons
dans les prisons nous prendrons la
mesure exacte du phénomène et des enjeux
et des moyens à mobiliser pour y
remédier tout à fait tout à fait
mais mais ça c'est un sujet d'importance
parce que quand on mène des opérations
au bout du bout c'est le résultat que
l'on
voit c'est-à-dire on il y a des faits
graves qui sont commis on interpelle on
défèire on condamne on prive de liberté
mais des fois on peut dire mais c'est
bizarre ils sont pas privés de liberté
alors qu'on a fait tout ce travail là
donc ça veut dire et ça je le disais
avec les j'en parlais avec les
procureurs généraux sous le contrôle de
monsieur Christen le dacg directeur des
affaires criminelles et des grâces au
ministère de la Justice en
fait c'est vrai qu'il est important pour
nous de bien nous synchroniser avec la
justice de manière à ce que l'effet
final soit vraiment l'effet recherché et
soit réellement recherché et
trouvé sur la structure de la population
effectivement vous la connaissez mieux
que moi monsieur le sénateur la moyenne
d'âge à Mayot euh est inférieur à 20 ans
euh c'est et et c'est une des
particularités si ce n'est la
particularité de de votre beau
territoire
euh comment le traiter là aussi une des
pistes c'est on l'a évoqué on l'a évoqué
avec le au ministère de la justice c'est
peut-être il y a des dispositifs
particuliers qui s'adaptent aussi au
mineurs ça peut être des des centres
éducatifs euh une présence accrue par
exemple bon je déborde un peu de mon
cadre mais en terme de réflexion de la
PJJ par exemple ça c'est important et là
ça serait effectivement là ça on
pourrait aller vers ces axes axes là je
P la justice a déjà réfléchi elle c'est
déjà dans leur tête c'est en tête de la
justice c'est très important de
s'adapter à la typologie effectivement
de mais de de la délinquence après je
neestime is pas non plus tous les
mineurs c'est bien évidemment mais on
sait très bien que notamment les mineurs
non accompagnés sont un sujet de
préoccupation
le les les sur les traducteurs alors moi
à ce stade je je n'ai pas eu de remonté
je vous le dis de de problématique de
traducteur je n'ai pas eu de
problématique de
traducteur moi j'ai été
àot il y a 2
semaines mais évidemment c'est CELI qui
m'a fait état de ce problématique
parfois on ne peut pas rendre la justice
parce queil y a pas de traducteur parce
que les gens ne savent pas parler
français alors rendre la justice c'est
au tribunal au tribunal moi je parle
dans l'exercice par exemple de la de de
notre mission de police judiciaire dans
les gardes à vu moi j'ai pas de
problématique de traducteur et chez nous
parce que en fait alors pourquoi on na
pas de problématique de traducteur parce
que jusqu'à ce
stade effectivement on a pas mal de on a
on a on a on a des compatriotes on a des
maorés et effectivement le le chimaoré
voire le le shiboui ben ce sont des
langues qui sont très très très parlées
très communes et on a pas mal de
gendarmes qui les parl et ça et c'est ça
l'intérêt effectivement ça fait le lien
avec ce que je disais avoir un un bon
équilibre entre avoir des originaires et
des non originaires sur les différents
territoires parce que l'aspect
linguistique et puis l'aspect aussi
culturel et cultuel pour Mayotte parce
que l'aspect cultuel est aussi très
important hein voilà donc ça c'est mais
effectivement sur la justice j'en avais
entendu parler mais sur la en
gendarmerie j'ai pas de j'ai pas ce ce
souc làà mais c'est vrai que il se passe
pas une journée c'est vrai quand sans
qu'on ait euh ben quelques exactions des
des barrages voilà euh ben vous le voyez
actuellement on a voilà mais après c'est
actuellement c'est d'autres barrages
voilà c'est c'est d'autres sujets
voà
merci je vais laiss
oui merci madame la Présidente mon
général ainsi que toute votre équipe je
veux avant tout profiter de l'occasion
puisque c'est vrai que c'est une
occasion qui est donnée à NS membres de
la délégation are maire du Sénat euh de
vous renouveler nos vœux enfin les vœux
de la Polynésie parce que étant présente
ici à Paris je n'ai pas pu aller à papéé
pour les vœux euh de commandement qui
est à papté euh merci pour euh
ce ce long faut dire constat que vous
venez de faire sur nos territoire aussi
bien département et collectivité euh
d'outre
mè moi je commencerai euh mon
intervention par par vous dire merci
pour la nouvelle brigade de monreéo euh
je je sais aussi dire merci quand il
faut dire merci parce que c'est vrai que
la population de Moréa euh a triplé pour
ne pas dire a été multiplié par 4 ou 5
surtout pendant le weekend tous ceux de
PAP éé de l'île de Thiti vont à Mora
c'était une nécessité de créer cette
nouvelle brigade merci pour ça pour moi
je dirais que je n'ai pas
euh je je n'ai pas vraiment de réserve
sur l'exercice de la
fonction au niveau de la gendarmerie sur
notre territoire parce que il faut le
reconnaître et ça je le dis c'était pas
le cas il y avait 20 ans mais beaucoup
de choses ont changé les gens se parlent
aujourd'hui les gens travaillent en
commun aujourd'hui parce que avant la
gendarmerie resté dans son carré euh
vous allez voir le le haut-comissaire et
ses équipes chacun dans son carré la
police nationale a pas été c'est c'est
l'État dans l'état les militaires à
Haroué au coms c'est autre chose alors
que on est tous sur un territoire et on
doit rendre service au même citoyens
enfin pour moi c'est mon raisonnement
comment doit se faire euh on parle de
l'État l'équipe France euh sur notre
territoire outre la complexité de nos
statuts ah ben ça vous avez énuméré le
le sujet du code de la route ben bien
sûr les routes compéten de la
collectivité du pays si au moins l'état
pouvait nous donner plus de millions
d'euros pour adapter euh nos routes
enfin c'est une évidence c'est c'est une
compétence du territoire euh on essaie
parout les moyens je suis élu en
Polynésie depuis 2001 euh comment faire
une vraie route tout autour de la
population quand je dois me lever à pas
le matin pour aller à été c'est plus que
pour moi de prendre l'avion àrière terre
euh en 40 minutes je suis à papté que de
par il me faut presque 3h si j'ai le
malheur de me lever un peu tard à 6h30
parce que là-bas il faut se lever à 4h
du matin les journées démarent tt c'est
pour ça que je redis sur l'exercice de
la fonction je n'ai pas de de de réserve
par contre
au niveau peut-être de la justice moi il
faut que la justice que le code pénal
qui est écrit à Paris soit la même que
celui qui est s'il y a une la peine de
je sais pas d'un stupéfiant de cannabis
doit être le même pour celui qui est à
Fakarava ou à et celui qui est à
Saint-Denis ou ou à maot je je parle de
la peine par contre je je vous
rejoindrai mon général pour dire
peut-être il y a des formes d'adaptation
par exemple pour un territoire comme le
le mien aussi vaste que l'Europe quand
il faut aller chercher un petit gars
à où il y a 200 armes le seul qui porte
un uniforme c'est le policier municipal
on fait
comment voilà ça je suis je suis aussi
comment dirais-je je reconnais il y a
voilà il y a tous ces contraintes toutes
ces contraintes de l'éloignement
de manque de moyens de la gendarmerie
pour y aller les seuls peut-être qui ont
les moyens c'est le petit C de la
commune cor parle des de l'archipelle
desto Moutou et c'est important pour moi
c'est pour ça que je redis beaucoup de
choses ont changé je salue beaucoup
toutes ces conventions signées entre la
gendarmerie quand je dis la gendarmerie
tout tout brigade confondu la
gendarmerie et et les brigades de police
municipale parce que ce sont des acteurs
aussi de terrain très proches et et qui
qui connaissent mieux nos populations
surtout dans le territoires les plus euh
reculés de la
Polynésie par contre j'ai c'est c'est
c'est c'est ma bataille ça à moi propre
à la sénatrice de Polynésie depuis que
je suis arrivé au Sénat c'est bien les
ressources humaines c'est mon combat et
jusqu'au au bout du dernier jour je
serai parlementaire c'est le retour euh
de nos enfants à compéten égales dans
nos territoires pour en 2024 parce que
ça fait 6 ans que je me bat pour ça
d'ailleurs j'ai déposer une PPL
peut-être pour un peu freiner à que ce
que tous les expatriés aent travailler
dans nos collectivité je demande à
supprimer tous les indemnités euh donné
euh au fonctionnaires d'État qui vont
dans les aresemains sauf la gendarmerie
militaire je touche pas à cela non mais
je je suis très précise parce que
pourquoi parce que pourquoi cette
frustration mon général cette
frustration est de plus en plus grande
dans nos territoirees et je parle à
compétence égale c'est la croix et la
bannière pour le petit et je parle pour
le Polynésien qui a 15 ans ou plus de
service ici en métropole et qui essaie
tant bien que mal de retourner sur notre
territoire bon je voulais quand même
vous vous interpellez il y en a eu quoi
un peut-être surv qui a eu la chance de
pouvoir repartir parce que derrière tout
ça c'est pas simplement de repartir
parce mon Général au-delà de l'uniforme
il y a avant tout l'humain aussi si nous
voulons réussir dans nos territoires je
crois c'est un des préalable aussi ça
c'est
l'humain c'est important enfin c'est
presque un cri de cœur que que je donne
ce matin mais voilà il faudra je je
je comment je vais m'explimer m'exprimer
ce matin c'est c'est c'est c'est un
appel de détresse il faudra un peu être
plus
regardant sur les les les demandes de
mou de personnel et avoir un peu un œil
bienveillant aussi sur les demandes pour
ceux qui méritent pour pour pour X
raisons mais je pense que après avoir
servi en métropole au-delà de 10 ans et
15 ans je crois ils ont toute la
légitimité de pouvoir repartir sur nos
territoires voilà ce que je voulais dire
merci merci Madame
présidente merci euh de votre présence
ce
matin et surtout de du travail qui est
fourni par euh vos militaires dans No en
are mè je sais que c'est un travail
difficile vous avez bien dit vous êtes
euh votre comment vous dit ça c'est
votre commandement
qui là où le soleil ne se couche jamais
c'est une vérité j'ai envie de dire que
c'est votre commandement c'est là aussi
où
la où la France en tant que pays
d'Europe qui a le plus de frontières que
tous les autres c'est une
réalité je dire pas là que ça sousentant
quand je parle de frontièrees je parle
de
frontière avec d'autres cultures avec
d'autres manièrees de voir de percevoir
et mon collègue Maillotte tout à l'heure
avec ces
problématiques qui qui arrive tous les
jours et
je je vois comment vous exercez je dis
nous avons passé également comme disait
mon
collègue euh tout à l'heure en
Nouvelle-Calédonie au sujet du 3ème
référendum où c'était sensible
la le travail en commun entre les maires
les exécutifs communales et les
gendarmeries ont fait que tout s'est
bien passé parce que on avait essayé de
faire ensemble que le travail et nous
les avons salué après le
travail en tant que président de
l'Association des Maires on avait saluer
le travail même si c'était un référendum
nous n'avons pas
participé éant indépendantiste mais on
l'a quand même salué le travail parce
qu'il fallait c'est toute la la sagesse
et l'intelligence de ce que nous avons
faire ça ce que je voulais vous demander
c'est en prologation de ce que ma
collègue Lana vient de dire sauf que
elle c'est par rapport à T ceux qui sont
ici qui doit
repartir et et ça je voudrais également
saluer le la sagesse de la
de la loiome qui a été pris en 2017 sur
le CIMM statut de
CIMM parce que c'est là où vous avez
répondu à ce que
Lana disait je pense que c'était une
réponse si c'était
pas je veux
dire bien précis dans la loi vous l'avez
précisé dans les
circulaires et
laquiétude
et l'esprit aujourd'hui qui est
contestablement positif sauf que
aujourd'hui je sais pas si il y a un
état des lieu qui fait qui a été fait à
travers de cette loi et surtout à
travers la cette circulaire l'idée c'est
que
les ultramarins puissent revenir chez
eux vous avez euh dans la circul je
crois si vous avez rajouté quelque chose
qui était qui était assez intéressant de
cluser c'est sur euh pour pouvoir
prolonger le séjour sur les
compétences techniques et linguistiqu
rares qui permet justement de répondre à
ce que le mon collègue sénateur de
Mayotte parlait tout à l'heure sur les
traductions c'est de pouvoir faire
rester le plus longtemps possible
certain nombre de militaires qui ont
cette compétence rare
là si l'état d'esprit est noble sage que
je
salue je trouve qu'aujourd'hui la la le
circulaire précise que au bout de 7
ans 6 ans 7 ans je sais plus il doivent
retourner en métropole et c'est toute la
question qui est
là parce que certains se sont
engagé
financièrement à
construire et quand on sait que le
retour en métropole est accompagné
souvent d'une
désindexation et donc quand il retourne
mopole en ayant déjà investi sur un
certain nombre de choses il se se trout
que
soit la plupart il y a beaucoup de de
militaires ce B beaucoup je veux dire il
y a des militaires qui ont qui décident
de démissionner
complètement parce que ils ont pas envie
de de venir ici en laissant leur famille
Ultramar chez eux et l'idée c'est de
dire est-ce que parce que le plus
souvent vous refusez le 10e et la 11e
année est-ce que j'ai compris vous me
corrigerez euh c'est l'idée c'est de
dire est-ce
[Musique]
que à l'image d'un Laurin d'un breton
qui continue à servir jusqu'à la fin de
sa carrière dans sa région et même un
peu déplé dans les juste dans le
départements à côté il n'y a pas de
possibilité pour ceux qui souhaitent ne
pas retourner en métropole de pouvoir
continuer jusqu'à terminer leur
service dans les autres m surtout dans
leur pays d'origine c'est toute la
question que je je je vous invite
aujourd'hui à que je pose voà bon vous
répondrez aujourd'hui vous me répondrez
un autre jour mais l'idée c'est de
pouvoir donner surtout à cette famille
parce que la plupart du temps quand vous
avez 11 ans de service vous entrez jeune
la plupart du temps 19 19 20 ans au bout
de
la 10e année vous avez 30 ans vous avez
trois gos cass gas vous avez investi sur
l'immobilier
et vous allez trimbaler tous ces enfants
tout en sachant que les rentrées
universitaires sont souvent différents
ici c'est on septembre nous avons fait
notre rentrée en
mars je sais pas pour les autres
peut-être tïti si vous avez les mêm euh
voilà et c'est souvent dans les
déplacement de ces familles aussi
nombreuses c'est souvent la vie de la
famille qui est affectée et je comprends
que ils ont fait le choix d'être
militaire euh je dis ils ont fait le
choix d'être militaire mais souvent
comme disait Lana aussi nous on voit
aussi ce côté humain ce côté hein donc
voilà la question que je je voulais vous
dire est-ce qu'il y a une possibilité du
pouvoir que vous regardez que dans les
demandes que vous avez de pouvoir en
plus des gens qui souhaitent repartir
dans les pays mais aussi pour ceux qui s
déjà le pays mais qui souhait rentrer de
pouvoir examiner dossier de par dossier
de pouvoir leur donner la
possibilité tout en sachant que cette
séparation creuse souvent des
difficultés financières et les met en
difficultés financière tant par
laexacence de leur de leur de leur
salair de les adinité et ça fait souvent
des problèmes ça fait souvent briser des
familles à cause de ça voilà
merci merci beaucoup de m'avoir écouté
avec tout le respect que je vous
do je va je vais je vais continuer à
vous parler
vrai pour moi la question des
originaires et suis pas à titre
personnel mais découvrant les outremèes
et je dirais ce que j'ai dit depuis
début mon
audition en fait je je j'ai fleur les
outremèes vous les connaissez beaucoup
mieux que moi bien évidemment bien
évidemment mais je m'en imprèigne et
donc je pense que
effectivement pour la G dans les ares
mè la problématique ou la qui est pas un
problème mais la problématique des
originaires pour moi est
essentielle et je le vois régulièrement
et
elle est essentielle à plusieurs titres
à la fois sur le plan quantitatif et sur
plan
qualitatif si vous me permettez je vais
je vais faire je vais faire une un focus
je vais faire je vais partir du général
au particulier et revenir au particulier
c'est qu'en fait je je vais parler des
outr-emè des originaires des outr-emèes
et ensuite je vais revenir sur vos
territoires si vous me
permettez on a quand même j'ai sur
ensemble tout statut confondu j'ai à peu
près on est à peu près sur le au niveau
des gendarmes entre c'est 26 % 26 %
d'originaire dans les territoire
ultramarin mais une fois qu'on a dit 26
% il y a de grosses diversités et moi
j'ai un vrai sujet alors pour le coup
c'est une vraie problématique avec un P
majuscule dans les Antilles et la
Guyanne euh j'ai un taux d'originaire et
je reviendra ensuite dans le
Pacifique qui est important certainement
pas suffisant je vous entends mais
important il y a un taux d'originaire
dans l'océan Indien y compris à Mayotte
et il faut le souligner les Maorais
veulent revenir à
Mayotte ils aiment leur terre
non mais comme tous les comme tous les
ultrarins mais quand je dis ça c'est
quand même important parce que il y a de
la
tension il y a de l'insécurité oui et le
travail est dur mais ils veulent revenir
mais ils veulent
revenir parce que ils ont leur
racine pour la petite histoire je faire
en sorte d'avoir je parle de l'océan
Indien
là depuis en 2024 là je vais faire en
sorte de mettre des maorés à la
Réunion parce que on a une problématique
à la Réunion c'est la problématique des
quartiers historiques de
Maoré on en a en en zone gendarmerie on
en a à Saint-Benoît on en a à la
possession on en a à Saint-Louis et
c'est des vrais
quartiers pour preuve on va créer une
brigade
mobile un peu comme Sandy Ground une
brigade mobile dans le quartier Maoré
qui compte plusieurs milliers de
personnes qui s'appelle le quartier de
brasfusil à
saint-boît mais à brasfusil j'ai besoin
de mauré je ça peut pas des exxagonaux
qui viennent à Saint-Louis j'en ai
besoin et en fait là je fais je je je je
je fais en sorte de dire je priorise
parce queil y a un besoin opérationnel
jusqu'àors il y avait aucun Maoré à la
Réunion alors que la population
maoraaise on peut avoir une importation
de certains mots malheureusement que
l'on connaît à Mayotte dans les
quartiers dans certains quartiers à la
Réunion et c'est une réalité moi j'en ai
parlé souvent avec avec mes gendarmes et
avec avec les élus à la Réunion c'est
une réalité et c'est une réalité qui qui
est grandissante ça donc ça on n espère
pas mais il faut essayer de le juguler
et on on le jugule aussi par la présence
d'originaire
et qui qui parle à une population mais
qui a le même culte que qu'elle qui qui
s'entend et qui qui se
comprennent sur les sur les Antilles
j'ai un vrai souci parce
que il y a très peu de très peu de
martiniqu de godadeloupéens qui veulent
servir sur leur territoire moins de 10
% moins de 10 % alors que je suis sur
alors qu'on sur des taux qui sont deux
fois plus de deux fois supérieurs dans
les autres territoires dont je parlais
je vais revenir sur ensuite sur la
Polynésie et la
NouvelleCalédonie en par exemple en
Martinique en Guadeloupe il n'y a que 8
% de sous-officiers
originaire alors même que je favorise
alors là je de favoriser les doubles
séjours et cetera c'est alors la Guyane
je nai que 7 7 c'est même pas je parle
pas de pourcentage 7 originaires
donc on a on a de grandes disparités
dans l'état é ultraarin on a des
Polynésiens et des polynésiennes
gendarmes qui sont engagés qui veulent
tous revenir je je je
caricature on a des Guyanais qui sont
engagés qui veulent pas venir et des
martiniquis des
guadeloupéens qui sont
engagés mais qui hésite à venir et qui
viennent plutôt en fin de
carrière pour pour quoi dire
pourquoi parce que Ben à un moment donné
ils sont soumis aussi à une pression
locale et l'analyse comme
comme une très grande difficulté à
exercer leur métier dans ces territoires
là peut-être à défaut mais c'est comme
ça que c'est pris c'est c'est c'est
voilà c'est c'est la perception l'état
d'esprit c'est qu' en Guadeloupe je
prends la Guadeloupe parce que j'envens
et encore la semaine
dernière bah c'est c'est dur c'est
effectivement les guadaloupéens ils sont
c'est dur d'être gendarme c'est
Guadeloupéens travailler en Guadeloupe
comme c'est dur c'est la c'est leur
perception peut-être qu'ils ont tort
mais c'est leur
perception en tout état de cause en tout
état de cause moi je vais essayer de
faire en sorte de favoriser alors
comment ça c'est qu'on on a des
commissions
euh au niveau de la gendarmerie alors
j'aime pas je prends pas le terme CMM
parce que c'est un terme
interministériel on a des commissions
qui visent à définir si tel ou tel
sous-officier a un lien avec le
territoire et bien très clairement moi
je vais faire l'effort sur on va
regarder des dossiers très on va faire
des efforts être souple pour les
martiniquis les Guadeloupéens les
guillanais c'est pour moi pour moi pour
moi c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
vraiment un effort enfin moi c'est un
mes axes d'effort très important alors
on peut favoriser effectivement le fait
de de d'atérer des Guyanais des
guadeloupiens des martiniquens mais il y
en
a en école ça c'est du plus long terme
mais à court terme c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il est plus de CIMM ou de lien
a de sousofficier un lien avec le
territoire martiniqueet guadeloupéen et
guyanet de manière à ce qu'il retravaill
chez eux j'ai besoin j' a besoin d'avoir
plus de lien avec la la
population et après il y a l'aspect
qualitatif mais je n'ai pas oublié la
Polynésie la nouvelle CAD vous inquiétez
pas je vais y revenir et il y a lien
qualitatif parce que quand on parle
quand on parle de de pourcentage ou de
nombre mais moi en tant que sgum com
Jama autres mè c'est parce que je
recherche forcément le pourcentage oui
je cherche à ce qu'il en ait plus mais
je cherche aussi à ce que
qualitativement les originaires prennent
des
responsabilités prennent des
responsabilités je suis en recherche et
de profil qu'on identifie au fur à
mesure de la carrière pour commander des
unités des orig je moi je cherche à
avoir plus d'originaires qui commandent
des unités qui a des responsabilités
comm unité de brigade quand brigade
adjoint commandant de Ploton de
surveillance et d'intervention de la
gendarmerie pourquoi parce que aussi ça
valeur d'exemple pour les originaire ça
valeur d'exemple l'originaire mais pour
pour il peut pas être que pourquoi il
serait que chef ou adjudant pourquoi il
serait pas adj chef majeur il comendrait
pas les
brigades et pour moi c'est essentiel
alors le but c'est pas de d'être sur
passer de 01 mais c'est ben d'infléchir
petit à petit ben voilà de manière à ce
qu'il y ait un bon équilibre également
dans les postes ralités et je dois dire
là que euh alors je fais maintenant je
mets la focale sur le Pacifique là sur
l'aspect qualitatif on on est on est
quand même madame la sénatrice pas
mauvais du tout en
Polynésie et moi je trouve ça très bien
on est en Polynésie on va une nouvelle
fois cet été avoir un coin de compagnie
polynésien vous le savez peut-être pas
mais je vous dirai mê pas son nom mais
ils sont pas nombreux hein vous le
connaissez certainement même très bien
pour ceux qui déjà je déc voilà voilà
mais je donnerai jeai pas de nom à la
radio comme on dit dans le monde
militaire on a on a un officier on a on
a deux compagnies pour pour pour tout le
monde il y a deux compagnies de
gendarmerie et a la compagnie des îles
du Vent la compagnie des archipels et
bien une des compagnies va être commandé
cté par un polynésien et c'est très très
bien et c'est très très bien et ça ça ça
ça montre effectivement mais qu'on a des
Polynésiens des originaires qui sont ben
chefs adjudant adjant chef major
lieutenant capitaine commandant et ça
c'est très bien donc l'aspect l'aspect
pour moi qualitatif est essentiel est
essentiel l'aspect qualitatif aussi est
important aussi en en nouvellecadonie on
a on a effec ent ben on a on a récemment
un un bah c'est à bouril hein un hein
Boulou Paris à Boulou Paris euh ben le
CAN de brigade qui est qui est
originaire et Ben qui a qui a pris son
commandement avec je crois j'ai vu des
photos on m'a dit une belle cérémonie
hein très belle cérémonie à la fois
républicaine gendarmerie mais également
coutumière hein mais c'est ça la parité
aussi de la gendarm Marie s'adapter au
coutume local c'est essentiel d'où les
originaires
aussi après sur le
nombre sur le nombre alors je je je vais
je vais me permettre madameatrice
actuellement en Polynésie tout statut
confondu hein c'està-dire officier
sous-officier et aussi les gendins
madjoint qui sont tous originaires donc
je mets pas les réservistes hein je mets
pas mais on a 52 % d'originaires en
Polynésie 52
%. on doit être euh je pense entre 25 et
30 % pour les
sous-officiers donc on peut toujours
faire
mieux on peut toujours faire mieux mais
faut-il faire plus c'est une question
c'est une question en en nouvelle mais
je vais y répondre en Nouvelle-Calédonie
en NouvelleCalédonie on est en
originaire on est à peu près à 25 %
sousofficier je crois que c'est 20 entre
20 et 25
% la problématique de la la
problématique de la de la nouvelle
cédonie c'est qu'en fait plus il reste
sur le territoire puis ils veulent venir
sur Néa moi j'ai un vrai sujet en
Calédonie je recherche des
Calédoniens quand je dis calédonien ça
veut dire
caldoch
Canac je recherche des Calédoniens pour
aller en
brousse ils se battent pas c'est un vrai
sujet parce que il y a la famille il y a
on est mieux dans nousé à sa banlieu
enfin ça se comprend donc
et pour pour pour pour pour pour tous
ceux qui écoutent c'est vrai que par
exemple la céonice en gros 3 je parle
sous votre contrôle he 300000 habitants
dont les deux tiers sont quand même sur
numea et la banlieu de numea c'est à peu
près ça c'est c'est à peu près ça mais
la brousse c'est hyper important et
kdonien il ve pas ils veulent pas
travailler en brousse
c'est tout le monde
ah il y a une île il y a une île où ils
aiment pas
aller alors là il y a une île en
Polynésie où ils veul pas aller parce
que déjà dans sur cette île là les les
les Polynésiens qui ne sont pas
originaires de cette île là polynésien
mais pas que gendarme ils sont pas bien
vu du
tout non Bora
Bora alors là alors là vous êtes
d'accord avec
moi les Polynésiens de ora peuvent pas
voir les autres et demander à un
polynésien gendarme d'aller à boraabora
alors qu'il est pas originaire de
BoraBora il vaudra jamais y aller non
c'est pour la petite c'est pour la
petite
histoire donc tout tout ça pour tout ça
pour tout ça pour dire que que oui on
essaie de discriminer madame la
sénatrice et monsieur le sénateur on
essaie de discriminer on essaie de faire
mieux
après moi je vous réponds je vous
réponds concrètement et en toute
transparence je je pense qu' on peut pas
aller vers un tout originaire c'est pas
possible il faut trouver un juste milieu
et pourquoi faut trouver un juste milieu
et là aussi on revient sur les temps de
présence alors on peut on peut on peut
dire on n pas d'accord ou pas d'accord
effectivement mais les temps de présence
sont les suivants quand on est
originaire on a un premier temps de
présence de 6 ans après on peut avir Une
prolongation de 3 ans et après on peut
avoir une prolongation exceptionnelle
c'est la 10e 11e année jusqu'à 11 ans
quand on est non originaire c'est 3 ans
1 + 1 + 1 jusqu'à 7 ans donc un origine
un un non originaire peut faire maximum
jusqu'à 7 ans mais il faut vraiment
c'est c'est sur des capacités rares
qu'on peut pas honorer il y a une
vacance de poste et l'originaire il peut
faire jusqu'à 11 ans ce qui arrive aussi
mais généralement il fait plutôt 9 ans
c'est vrai et il faut savoir également
que l'originaire qui a moins de 5 ans de
la limite d'âge il reste sur le
territoire c'est qu'un originaire qui
calcule
bien s revient sur son territoire à
moins donc euh si c'est 39 15 s s'il
revient à moins de 14 ans de sa limite
d'âge il finit sur son
territoire alors c'est pas satisfaisant
vous dites effectivement il y a il y a
des prêts et cetera il y a la famille
mais quelque part quand ils se sont
engagés ils le savaient
ça c'est pas le le contrat de départ
c'est pas un contrat qui est
biaisé après il y a les après il y a la
vie il y a la vie qui fait
que mais exactement mais bien sûr a
a il y a la famille il a le papa qui va
mal il y a la sœur qui a un problème de
santé et moi j'essaie j'essae enfin et
je peux vous dire qu'en tant que ségom
je fais en sorte d'accorder une
attention à chaque cas moi je fais du
surmesure et là je peux vous le dire je
j'envoie régulièrement des cas quand je
pense vous m'avez posé la question sur
la Calédonie je vais vous dire à quoi
j'ai pensé je vais vous donner un cas
particulier qui qui montre que on fait
du surmesure et donc sur mesure ça peut
dire on peut pas donner gain de cause à
tout le
monde un cas sur mesure il y a un
gendarme qui a fait des bêtises un
Calédonien il a fait des bêtises il y a
pas longtemps enfin il y a 6 mois parce
que je je l'ai vu je l'ai vu je l'ai vu
quand j'y suis passé donc en septembre
dernier il a fait des grosses
bêtises c'est un très bon
gendarme il est euh il était sanctionné
et s posé la question de le sortir de
son unité parce qu'il pouvait plus
rester dans son unité je dis pas
laquelle il pouit plus rester j' avait
le choix est-ce qu' quitte la
Calédonie le type c'est c'est un c'est
un très très bon gendarme donc ça veut
dire que il avait deux enfants déjà sa
femme travaille à Nea deux enfants et sa
femme était enceinte d'un troisème
enfant qu'est-ce que je
fais je l'envoie dans l'Hexagone au
risque son couple éclate qui parte
lui-même en vrille parce que c'est ça la
réalité ça peut être ça et qu'on perde
un gendarme bah ce que j'ai fait
ben je
l'ai muté sur une île en
Calédonie donc c'est pas l'Hexagone mais
reste en calédonis donc il était sur une
île donc là il est parti pour faire pour
j'ai pas purger sa peine c'est pas ça
mais il est parti sur une des plus
belles
îles de la Nouvelle-Calédonie non je
diraiis pas de nom
voilà il est parti il est parti et il
m'a remercié parce que comme ça comme ça
il il continue être gendarme
il sa femme peut continuer être Nea il
fait des liaisons avec Nea et et voilà
et on a on trouve un équilibre donc ça
c'est ce que j'appelle du surmesure
voilà par exemple et donc j'essaie on
essaie de faire ça au cas par cas
j'étais un peu long mais pour moi la
problématique des originaire franchement
enfin je c'est quelque chose que je j'ai
j'ai c'est un vrai sujet c'est un vrai
sujet ETI
oui mais et et je vous avouis vous avez
compris mon sujet moi c'est c'est plutôt
sauf les cas par cas c'est
surtout les Antilles les Antilles et la
Guyane c'est c'est important voilà alors
je je vais clore ces cette série de
questions évidemment par
sy juste deux questions la première
question c'était monsieur mon Général
madame la Président vous m'avez donné la
parole comment préparez-vous mon Général
vos responsables avant la prise de poste
dans un territoire de trouè ça c'est
vous l'avez je sais pas si vous l'avez
répondu ou pas et sur la partie
coopération internationale avec
l'immigration que nous avons à mayott
comment vous travailler avec les
Comor serait-il possible parce que nous
sommes vraiment contra par par le temps
je vous laisse 2 minutes et après nous
allons parce
que
donc la partie donc coopération
internationale on a on a un attaché de
sécurité intérieure qui est qui est au
commore avec lequel on est en liaison
constante lui-même est en en liaison en
relation avec l'ensemble des
services
comorien et notamment mais le service
comorien qui qui a le plus d'action
judiciaire c'est la gendarmerie
comorienne donc c'est la gendarmerie une
gendarmerie sœur on a des contacts qui
sont établis avec nos gendarmes nos
camarades gendarmes Comoriens on a des
des des tunnels établis et on échange
régulièrement alors ça peut toujours
être plus efficient bien évidemment mais
euh on n'est pas très clairement on
n'est pas à l'état zéro mais d'un autre
côté ce que voyez par rapport à
rapidement à l'action de la gendarmerie
il y a ce qui est visible et ce qui est
moins visible ce qui est visible c'est
l'action de terrain quand on voit ce qui
est moins visible et ce qui est surtout
le fruit du de la coopération c'est
l'échange de renseignement et en vue
d'investigation judiciaire et ça ce
temps-là c'est parfois aussi un temps
long et c'est pas forcément le temps de
l'immédiaté et le le premier point
comment vous préparez vos ouais comment
est-ce qu'on comment est-ce qu'on
prépare en fait déjà c'est un appel à
volontaire qui est fait donc c'est des
gens qui sont sélectionnés qui sont
volontaires pour servir autre mère
ils sont déjà informés avec leur famille
parce que le genendarme quand il se
déplace il se déplacee avec sa famille
donc c'est une aventure à la fois
professionnel et familial et
personnel ils sont en fonction des
postes dans lequel ils sont ils font des
stages préparatoires tous les stages se
font dans l'Hexagone avant affectation
les seuls St les seuls stages pardon qui
se font durant affectation ce sont pour
les originaires parce qu'ils ont un
temps d'allonge qui est plus important
voilà donc la préparation se fait à la
fois familialement par avant l'appel à
volontaire en matière de recrutement et
une fois que le personne est sélectionné
ça se fait sur la base de module de
stage avant affectation et quand ils
arrivent sur le territoire chaque comme
gandre prend en compte les nouveaux
arrivants pour lui donner bah les
quelques clés les clés importantes bah
d'arriver sur le territoire parce que
ben on on on ne fonctionne pas avec avec
populations ultramarine comme on
fonctionne avec une population
hexagonale voilà c'est même dans le
toucher le regard ce que l'on dit ce que
l'on dit pas voilà ce que vous savez
parfaitement
voilà merci donc pour revenir
saint-bartelémi vous avez insisté
justement sur euh la l'ancrage dans le
territoire bénéficier bon chez nous nous
n'avons pas encore de de gendarmes
originair de de sa barelémie toutefois
il existe un statut le statut de
Polynésie dans saint bartelémie est
aussi une collectivité de de l'article
74 de la Constitution qui permet aux
policiers municipaux polynésiens de
bénéficier d'un statut d'officier de
police judiciaire
adjoint et je me demandais si à
saint-barthelémie en ayant si on pouvait
uvrer en demandant que N nos policiers
territoriaux puissent bénéficier de de
ce statut est-ce que vous pensez qu'il
pourrait y avoir une une collaboration
un peu plus accru avec les services de
la gendarmerie en poste sur nos sur
notre dans notre territoire et et tracé
attainement élargi aussi à Saint-Martin
qui a le même statut que saint-martelémi
et ma deuxième question plus générale
vous avez parler des des jeunes il y a
un dispositif dans les territoires qui
marchent pas mal plutôt spécifique au
territoire ultramarin qui est le RSMA
est-ce que la gendarmerie peut
travailler en collabor avec le RSMA pour
inciter aussi des des jeunes ultramarins
à se à s'investir dans la gendarmerie
d'une manière générale ou dans des
services spécialisés de de la
gendarmerie sur la première question
madame la sénatrice sur la première
question le oui je pense qu'il faut
qu'on étudie ça très clairement euh
après faut peut-être pas le le mettre
faudrait pas mettre en œuvre partout
mais le mettre en re de manière ciblée
mais ça je je retiens l'idée bien
évidemment
euh sur
la sur la deuxième question
euh euh sur le RSMA le RSMA euh en fait
ce que l'on fait c'est que
euh on travaille avec les différents
régiments du service militaire adapté
pour mettre en place ils mettent en
place des des classes euh dédiées au
métier de la sécurité donc ça marche pas
mal ça c'est que ça permet effectivement
là on travaille en collaboration avec le
ministire adapté pour justement faire en
sorte à partir de ces classes de lié
dédié au métier de la sécurité d'en
faire quelque part l'antichambre de la
du recrutement en gendarmerie que ce
soit un gendarme adjoint volontaire voir
en sous-officier donc c'est là où on
trouve ce lien et je trouve que cette le
SM1 c'est bien parce que bah c'est moins
je dirais ça c'est moins répressif au
premier abord et donc donc c'est un
premier pas une forme comme je disais de
SAS et là après effectivement il y a une
forme de détection et puis d'envie ou
pas du jeune de pouvoir aller plus loin
et s'engager ou pas
voilà merci donc avant de avant de
conclure permettez-moi de
de de vous adresser toute ma
reconnaissance et ma gratitude euh par
votre investissement au sein des des
collectivités et des territoires puisque
vous nous avez démontré tout au long
cette cette audition que vous non
seulement vous vous connaissez ces
territoire mais vraiment dans les
moindres euh avec passion et dans les
dans les moindre dans les moindres
détails donc j'ai retenu euh que trois
grands axes euh de votre travail
notamment privilégi donc le cas par cas
et vous avez aussi euh euh bien témoigné
de la diversité de de chaque territoire
et et et la nécessité d'apporter euh des
des réponses
adaptées euh vous avez aussi évoqué la
mise en place de projets innovants pour
répondre à des problématiques bien
ciblées comme le dispositif harpi en
Guyane comme la la brigade conjointe
entre les mobiles la gendarmerie et des
policiers soit territoriux à
Saint-Martin soit municipaux à à la
Réunion et euh parallèlement le
renforcement de la coopération régionale
donc ce qui montre bien ce sont les deux
études la délégation a décidé de Lan de
lancer donc cette étude sur
l'adaptation des des missions de l'État
dans les territoire ultrarin d'une part
mais nous avons aussi lancé une étude
triénale sur justement la coopération
régionale par bassin océanique donc je
vous renouvelle mes remerciements parce
que votre intervention montre aussi à
quel point C deux ces deux études sont
très importantes pour nos territoires
ultramarins voilà je fait je vous je
remercie aussi les collègues d'être
restés euh aussi longtemps c'était une
audition euh assez longue mais très très
passionnante et nous avons aussi j'ai
découvert aussi j'ai appris énormément
euh à vos côtés donc nous restons à
votre à votre disposition et si vous
pouvez nous apporter des éléments des
contributions écrites elles seront les
bienvenu merci à vous merci à à madame
la Présidente et bien à vous toutes et
tous euh moi je reste à votre
disposition dans le cas de votre étude
si vous AZ des questions pour moi j'y
répondrai bien évidemment par par écrit
faut faut pas
hésiter